- The amounts of blisters.
I've gotten from Mario Party, man.
- This one right?
- My god, whoever designed the like-
- Sick fuck, sick fuck.
- Like he just hated humanity.
He woke up and he chose violence.
(gentle hiphop music)
Gamers, welcome to this very
special episode of Trash Taste.
I'm your host for today, gamer,
and with me is gamers and gamers.
(laughs)
How are you doing gamers?
- It wasn't that funny,
I mean seriously, Garnt
says gamer, Man loses it.
- It just was the most forceful,
gamers, that I've ever.
I was like oh shit.
As a gamer I was not prepared for that.
- As a gamer you're not prepared.
- So we all play video games.
We're gamers, right?
So I thought today that
we could talk about,
our tastes in gaming,
because I think we, we've spoke
about what we like to play,
and, and all that,
but we haven't actually sat down,
and reviewed each other's gaming,
- Properly talked about it.
- Or at least tell each
other our gaming tastes.
- We've had like the anime episode,
where we've properly broken
down our anime taste.
Even though we've talked
about anime before,
and we're going to be doing
something similar today.
So we have made three, three
by threes for our games.
We don't, unfortunately we
don't have a, my gaming list,
which probably would have made it,
- Why is that not a thing?
- I don't know?
- That should be a thing.
Oh I'm sure there's like
an equivalent of it.
- I'm sure there's a thing of that,
but it's just not, I don't know.
It's just not as prevalent in
the gaming community, I feel.
- I guess it's because it
takes longer to finish a game,
than to finish an anime.
- And it, I'm going to be honest.
It made this a lot harder,
'cause I couldn't remember
like most of the games I play-
- Garnt literally can't remember.
- Garnt's not a gamer.
It's just proven.
- (laughs) Like I'm not looking
forward to this episode,
because I'm probably
going to have the most,
boring gaming tastes, out of everyone.
- Look Garnt's literally be like,
the top selling games of all time.
That's it.
- Wii Sports nine times. (laughs)
- Tetris, Wii Sports.
- Like for me,
we were making a three by
threes at the same time,
and they used to finish within 10 minutes,
and I, after about half
an hour, I made six,
and I'm just like are there
nine games I really care about?
I don't fucking know.
- Have I even finished
nine games in my life?
- Is there nine games I care about?
What, what are you, a person
in a retirement home, like.
- There's more than nine games.
- No, I have games that
I played that I enjoyed,
but like games that like
really meant something to me,
or games like I think back
and have like a positive,
memory of.
- What, what?
You just think like I hated it.
- Every game I've played.
- This is the 50th time,
this has happened now,
where I didn't enjoy it.
- There were just so many
games where I'm just like,
yeah that was a game I played.
I enjoy-
- Mother, Father,
please stop giving me shitty games.
I don't want to play any shitty games.
- I enjoyed my time with it.
I dunno.
- I'm excited for this one.
Cause I feel that, you know, with anime,
you guys are like definitely
the resident experts, right?
I feel like gaming this is like, this is.
- This is your time to shine.
- This is my time.
- The reverse, the roles
have been reversed.
- I mean, look if there's
anything we know about,
the gaming community is that they love,
to shit on other people's
opinions, all right.
It's like, I feel like,
regardless of what we put on here,
there's going to be at least
one person being like amateur,
fucking normies right here.
- Oh, definitely, definitely.
- I mean depends, you know-
- I mean I'm fully prepared for I'm fully,
I fully realize I'm a normie
when it comes to games so,
I'm okay with that, to be honest.
- No, you think you're a normie?
I think I am the most normie gamer,
of all time.
- The Normie Lords.
- Considering the list of games,
that I've actually completed is like,
I can probably count on my hands.
- Wait, why, why do
you not complete games?
- I don't go, I find it super,
super hard to complete games.
- It needs to be like a really good game.
- No, no, that's the
thing, that's the thing.
Most of the game, like,
because I tried to find
the criteria of like,
what I would put on my list, right?
And for anime,
it was anime that I have
at least re watched once.
For gaming I was just like,
if I complete that, if
I complete the game,
then that's like a fucking
STA game in my eyes.
Because if it's, if, if I
get to the end of the game,
it must be a truly special game,
- Imagine if people did
this for like movies.
They're like its a good
movie, if I get to the end.
Like normally, I log off.
- Yeah, 10 out of 10,
- It's like reading an
IGN review being like,
"I finished it nine out of 10,"
- Because like, for me, for
me, like the most, most of,
most games I get to that 70%
mark of completion, right?
And at the 70% Mark, it's like,
you've discovered most of the things,
the game can do for you.
And like you've unlocked
most of the abilities-
- I dunno, there's some
games they're like,
they literally don't end
until they end, like.
- Like which games?
- I dunno.
- Any on your list,
or just any?
- Some of my games?
Yeah, actually.
- You talking about like,
like online games?
- Well if you're doing
story games, you know,
obviously you can't just quit
70% of the way and be like,
I've seen the story.
- I mean, like there are-
- I mean, you'd be surprised.
- You'd be surprised.
- I mean JRP,
that's not a story, that's,
that's a fucking dictionary.
You know unusual knowledge.
- Right.
- And that's why I think for me,
story's a massive thing,
because if it doesn't have a good story,
I ain't finishing the game.
- No I agree with that.
- If it don't have a
good enough game play,
I ain't even starting the game.
And I, I'm like, I realized,
I'm such a fucking picky gamer.
If there is just one aspect of a game,
that just doesn't mesh
with me immediately,
then I just end up not playing it.
- Is there anything that annoys
me more than a picky eater,
it's a picky gamer. (laughs)
Finish your game.
- Especially now when I just
don't have time to play games.
If I'm playing a game, I play like,
I think I play one or two games a year.
New games.
Like it's hard not to just
go back to my comfort food,
and play games I've played before.
- I've such a bad habit on that.
Where if there's ever like a new game,
that just comes out, I don't
care, it doesn't matter,
if I just started a new
game three days prior.
I'll just be like, I don't
want to play with you anymore.
And then I just play
that, you know like, so.
Just three days ago as
of us recording this,
the new Monster Hunter game came out,
and I was like, well I was
going to play that anyway.
So it's fine.
But I was really busy up
until these last three days.
So I only just picked it up yesterday.
But before that, like right
before Monster Hunter came out,
I had got the new Super
Mario game as well.
So I had played that new Super Mario game,
for like literally four days.
And then I was like, Monster
Hunter's out, all right.
See ya.
- I do that sometimes.
- I just,
immediately started a new game.
- I mean, if it's like a really, you know,
highly anticipated game
that you're waiting for,
I mean I get it.
- Oh no, but I'm like that with, right?
Like if there's like a new game on Steam,
that's like, oh, it's 20% off.
I guess I'll give it a go.
Like, I feel like I'm one of those like,
if we comparing it to like
people who eat food, right?
I'm definitely one of those people,
who just takes little
bits off of the buffet,
but doesn't actually finish
what's on their plate,
before they go onto it.
Whereas there are some
people who are like,
no I'm getting one thing,
and I'm not going to
move on to the next meal,
until I finished it, right?
- Okay so, you know when
it was like Christmas,
or your birthday.
You ever ask for more than one video game.
Did you ever do that.
- No.
- You never had more than one video?
- I did,
but he was like a hail
Mary I'm just like, maybe,
maybe this is the year that will happen.
Maybe Santa really loves me this year.
- And if you get like two or
three games in one, you know,
birhtday or Christmas,
it's like, how do you,
whoa, whoa, where, who do I begin with?
How do I split this time evenly like?
- That sounds like first
world problem to me.
- That is the most first world problem.
- I think my seven year old life peaked,
when I got a entire game
console for Christmas,
I got an N 64.
And that was like, man,
my career's peaked.
I am, life is never
going to peak after this.
What am I, what am I even living for, man?
- I was like that when I
got the game boy advance,
when I was like five.
I was like, (panting) there's
so much power in my hands.
Every other, every other
thing I've ever done,
out the window.
- 'Cause like one of
the big problems I had,
when making my three by three was that,
there were games that I
knew I loved as a kid.
But then I don't remember fuck about them.
- Well there's some where if
you asked me to play them now,
I'm sure I could be like,
I don't remember exactly what happened.
All I know is that I put way
too many hours into this,
like I, so, yeah I mean,
we just get into that,
and then we can talk about
other gaming stuff after.
- Yeah, sure, sure,
- Sure, sure, let's get to it.
- All right, should we get Trash Can.
I think our names are
still on the ballots.
- Oh, are they?
- Are they, are they?
- Let's figure it
- Okay.
- They are,
well let's find out who's
going to be roasted first.
- Do you wanna go first?
- Oh okay, I can see the names.
Let me, let me not look.
- Would you like to go first-
- I can see literally my name.
- And the first one is,
- Oh, it's Garnt.
- It's Garnt.
- Oh, it's me.
Okay, starting things off easy I see.
- I can't wait, this is going to be fun.
- Is there anything you boys
expect on this gaming list?
- I have a feeling that League
is going to be on there.
(laughing)
- I have a few, yeah.
- As far as anything else goes,
League, I expect to be on there.
I don't know what other
games you've played.
You never talk about video games.
- I don't talk about
video games often, do I?
- You're like hentai, anime-
- Hentai, anime, video games
what video games do I play?
- I swear to God, if Fate
is on here, I'm gonna be,
I'm gonna be so angry.
If Fate/Grand Order is on here.
- Yeah, I didn't put Fate on here,
because I mean, I play, I don't know.
- Did you think about
putting Fate on here?
- I did put-
- No!
- I did think about putting not Fate,
but Genshin Impact on there.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
I was really,
really fucking into it.
- It made a big Impact,
in your life, you could say?
- Okay, then you want to go
through the nine games you have.
- All right, so starting at
the top Mass Effect Three,
Tales of Symphonia, Persona
Five, Zelda Wind Waker,
League of Legends, Super Mario Sunshine,
Metal Gear Solid Three,
Subnautica, Gears of War Two.
I look at this and I'm just like,
this is the most random fucking,
list of games.
- I was not expecting,
like half of the games you put on here.
- I honestly, I expected myself
to be more anime games on,
and I'm just realizing,
what I haven't really finished any games.
- And the only really anime
games on here is probably,
Symphonia and Persona, right?
- Yeah, and those are the
only, like I'm thinking,
what other anime type
games series are there,
that are famous?
Because when I think of anime video games,
I'm just like Tales
series, Persona series.
Those are the only anime video games that,
I've actually finished.
- There's like Xeno Saga,
like Xenoblade,
- So why, 'cause I've only
ever played one Tales game.
I've played Tales of Berseria.
- Berseria.
Oh that's the, that's the not good one.
- It's the not good one?
- No Berseria wasn't that good.
- The one with the woman, with the,
- The red and black.
- Yeah.
- Yeah that's Beseria, yeah.
- I got quite far in, from me.
Got like 20 something
hours in and I was like-
- Wow!
20 hours into a JRPG?
- That's impressive.
- I was like.
God this is so boring.
(laughing)
Literally like all the
fights are the fucking same.
- That's, that's, oh
yeah, welcome to JRPGs.
- Yeah, like I'm completely,
okay so here's the thing
for the longest time,
I've really, really
tried to get into JRPGs.
Like as a kid, the reason,
the reason Tales is on here,
is that as a kid, I like,
I knew I would love JRPGs,
and like the aesthetic and
the story and everything,
because I love anime.
The problem is I hated turn-based battles.
Like I couldn't fucking
stand turn-based battles.
And that would like put me
off getting more than say,
five hours to any JRPG,
because I would just get turned off,
by the turn-based battles.
And so I was like, as a kid,
I was waiting for a game
that was an anime game,
that just did not have a
turn-based battle system,
and also random encounters.
I fucking hate random encounters, as well.
- Random encounters suck.
- Wait, wait, okay but
you say that though,
but Persona Five is literally that.
- I know.
Okay, Persona Five, it doesn't
have random encounters,
but Persona Five is literally the game,
that broke JRPGs for me because-
- Well I mean, even as
someone who hasn't played it,
or plays JPGs, it's still
that JRPG that I look at,
and I'm like, I know that's a good game.
Like I don't need to play it
to know, that's a good thing.
You just look at it and you can-
- I wouldn't play it, but it's good.
- Like I can see everything about it,
that this is a banger of a game.
I'm not going to play it,
because I don't own a
console that can play it.
And honestly, do I want
to get into that shit?
No, but it's, it looks
like a fucking good game.
- Like with Persona Five.
I dunno, it was,
it's the only turn-based battle game,
where I just didn't get
bored of the battle system,
and I don't know why, it's something.
I think it's-
- It's the theme man.
- It's, it's a bit of everything, right.
Because it just it's really
good at tricking your mind,
into thinking that this
isn't turn-based battle.
That's that's the best way I can describe-
- Which is by the
sexiest animations alive.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's just got like so many
colors, the music fucking slaps.
You can like, you get different
abilities as you go on.
And I don't know, like
it's, it's something,
it's really good at tricking
your mind into thinking,
man this is, this just,
it just feels almost like a
rhythm game at points, you know?
It's, it's, I can't put my words on why,
that battle system out of everything,
just trumped any other JRPG battle system.
Because I can't, I can't think
of any other JRPG I enjoy.
Even though, I say I'm
a JRPG enjoyer, right?
I have the most basic JRPG taste-
- So then Tales of Symphonia
there specifically.
- Tales of Symphonia, okay so,
- Because for me, if I
were to put a Tales game,
'cause I've played most
of the Tales games,
- I've played one Tales game,
I don't know what the fuck was happening.
So if you wanna explain
to me what it's about,
'cause I legitimately don't know anything,
and I'm sure the viewers
who haven't played it-
- 'Cause if I were to put a
Tales game on there personally,
I would put Zestiria on there.
- Yeah, which one is Zestiria again?
- Zestira's the one after Symphonia.
- Okay, I would have put,
the only one I can think of Vesperia,
which is, which is like,
I'm just throwing out
words for Connor here.
- They all sound so
similar, Vesteria, Vesperia?
- I mean it's like Final
Fantasy one, two, three, four,
five six.
- I can follow along,
with the numbers, I'm pretty good at that.
(laughing)
I think I've got that down.
- I know six comes after five.
- Pretty sure I'm aware of that.
- Yeah, I mean, I mean the
best way I can describe it,
it's just basically a,
it's just basically anime
as, anime the video game.
Like it's, it's really that simple.
JRPGs are just to me,
I know I can get into most JRPGs,
if I like the combat and battle system,
because it's just anime
the video game, right?
And I like anime.
I'm a Wiebe.
Therefore equation equals, you
like the Tales series, right?
And the reason Tales of
Symphonia won there was,
it was my first experience
with just realizing that,
whoa, you can play a video game,
and it feels like you're
watching an anime?
Whoa, this is, this is amazing.
I get like, I can't,
I can't believe I've just
discovered this in my life.
And I was so obsessed with
this, right, because it's,
these are two of the only
JRPGs I've ever finished,
but I was so obsessed with it,
that I got to the 80% point
as I do with most video games.
And then I just stopped playing it,
and I didn't stop playing
it because I got bored.
I stopped playing it,
because I didn't want
that experience to end.
I didn't, I didn't want
to see the end credits,
and know that that experience was over.
So like I stopped playing it for about,
I held onto that for
about two fucking years.
- Jesus Christ!
- Just so, just so I know that I have,
I have the ending of Tales of Symphonia,
to look forward to in my life.
Like that, that was, that
was like the peak of life.
After the N64.
- Man you must be able to,
hold a nut.
- You literally blue balls yourself.
- Yeah Garnt's like, I'm
gonna blue ball myself.
That's that monk control kicking in.
God damn!
- The funny thing is,
so I'm just like after,
after about two years I'm like okay,
I think it's time to
complete Tales of Symphonia.
Start playing-
- I think it's time to nut.
- Yeah, I think it's time to finally nut.
Start playing it again,
and then I realize,
fuck I don't know anything,
I can't remember anything that's going on.
So what did I do?
I just replayed it from the beginning.
And I was like 80 hours in already.
So I've put like a good 150,
160 hours into this game.
Persona Five, I actually,
haven't replayed, because-
- I mean it's quite long isn't it?
- It's quite a long,
it's quite a long game.
And it compared to Tales when I was a kid,
I had plenty of time to
fucking replay games back then-
- 'Cause I assume Persona's
probably on your list as well.
'Cause you've played twice, right?
- Oh I've played Persona Five, four times.
- You played it more than me,
but I remember the reason
Persona's on there,
is that out of like a lot
of games in my adult life,
like for the first time
in a long time, you know,
it felt like I was a kid again.
And I was just like,
- How, how can I, how can
I put this into words.
When I experienced Persona Five,
I didn't know that I could feel this way.
Just like being really excited,
about just being really
excited about game,
and just discovering this new world.
And God, I, I'm-
- I killed my feelings,
when I was an adult,
and then Persona Five reminded me.
- It really did, it really did.
I don't know.
I was just like, yo, this is anime,
and it's a video game.
I'm enjoying it again.
It's, it's like,
it's like discovering anime
for the first time again.
And yeah like I, I always,
I always, everyone always told me,
you know, you're like the Persona series.
You're like, the Persona series.
And I'm just like,
no, I fucking won't, it's got
turn-based battles in there.
Why the fuck would I like that?
It's got turn-based battles, and then-
- But dude, they are
like the worst system,
of any combat system, any
game, like, it's like.
- Far and beyond.
One of the few things I can
agree on donkey with, you know?
And that's like the big reason
why I haven't, you know,
I couldn't get into a lot
of the Final Fantasies.
Never played Final Fantasy Seven.
I'll probably start playing
Final Fantasy Seven remake,
because that doesn't
have turn-based battle.
- I mean, I was telling myself,
I was gonna play Final Fantasy Seven,
for like the past 10
years and I never did.
Well because it's one of those games like,
I'm going to play it.
Yeah, of course, I'm going to play it.
It's Final Fantasy Seven.
- Well, I mean, yeah, then
the time passed, yeah.
- But I mean, I remember,
I did boot up Final Fantasy
Seven, the first time, on Steam,
And I was like-
- Oh the play station,
the original one?
- Yeah I'm like,
oh, it's hideous.
- Yeah it looks like absolute shit.
- I was like, I can't do this.
- Like Cloud with the eggbeater hands?
It looks fucking horrible, now.
- Yeah, because I, you
talked about, you know,
when a new hype game comes out,
then you just drop
whatever you're playing,
and just start playing that.
I have like the opposite problem,
I have, I dunno what,
I dunno if there's an actual term for it.
I think, I think I'm going to,
I'm just going to coin a term now,
I get hype fatigue, right?
So like, there are times when I see,
I see a new game, like
announced at E3, or something.
I see, or I see all like the, you know,
the gameplay and like the developers,
showing off gameplay footage and trailers.
And I'm like, I like follow through that.
I'm like super, super hype for this game,
because I think I'm really
going to like this game.
And I get so hype that I kind
of hype myself out of it,
once the game actually comes out.
- You've used all your hype.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's, it's so weird.
Like I was like that with the
Final Fantasy Seven remake,
because I'm like,
dude I can finally enjoy
Final Fantasy Seven,
because this removed the shitty part,
that I hate about Final Fantasy,
the turn-based combat and
the random encounters.
So in theory, I should love this game,
because this is one of the
greatest JRPGs of all time.
Everyone always talks about it.
I was hyped for it to come out.
I was hyped for it for
years, and then it came out,
and then I just was just like,
maybe I'll play it later.
- That's a really good point.
I think that League of Legends,
killed my ability to get hyped for games.
'Cause I knew that at the end of the day,
most of the time I would just
return to League of Legends.
So it didn't matter what
game came out anyway,
because I would play it for a week,
and then I'd be like,
all right back to League.
It's like, and so now,
even though I don't really
play League anymore,
even when a game that I
probably am excited for,
like is announced or
whatever, I'm just like,
well someone's on Twitter going,
you know the fucking, like every letter.
I'm just like oh,
this is cool,
- I mean yeah,
- I'll play it when it comes out.
- It's kind of like that, you
know, whole thing of like,
oh like a new restaurant just opened up,
that everyone's fucking out
about, I'll go check it out,
but then you go have a meal there.
Might be the best fucking
meal of your life,
but then, you know, you'd be like,
all right I'm going to
McDonald's tomorrow.
It's just, it's just comfort food, right.
Or comfort game versus like,
there's always that like
full back of, yeah you know,
this is a cool game and all,
and like I'm sure I'll love it,
if I just kept going on with it.
But at the same time,
it's like, I'll just,
I'll just replay this thing.
- I wonder as well, if
you're into story games more,
which I think the people who
are chasing like the hype,
are more into story games,
'cause when you're a multiplayer
gamer, mainly like me.
It's like, well I'm
just gonna keep playing,
the same fucking game.
So like, why would I
get hyped over anything?
When, if there's a new game,
I'll probably end up switching to it.
If it's a new multiplayer game.
So it's kind of hard for me to
get hyped about story games.
- It's like a catch 22 for me, right?
Because I really value good
stories in video games.
But also like, especially now as an adult,
I think I just have
commitment issues with games.
Like, unless I know that
I'm going to be committed,
to this game for the next week of my life,
which finding hard, finding
time to commit to a game,
for the next week of my life,
is like a big fucking commitment, now.
It is, it is so hard,
that sometimes I just go
back to my comfort food,
of just like maybe replaying Mass Effect.
Like when, when Cyberpunk got released,
I was super, super hyped about Cyberpunk,
and then it got released,
and then I'm just like,
I don't really feel
like playing Cyberpunk,
and I just started
playing Mass Effect again.
(laughs)
Because.
- But you can't,
choose your dick size in Mass Effect.
- 'Cause I know the story of Mass Effect.
I know I'm going to enjoy
the story of Mass Effect,
and I know, I think
over, pre overexposure,
in terms of like gaming
is a big thing for me,
because a lot of people hype
up games to no, to no end.
And I don't think that people,
I don't think in anime at least
this is as big of a problem.
Or as big of like a thing where people do,
you know, people get hyped
about anime as it's airing.
People rarely get hyped about anime,
or super, super hyped about
anime before it starts airing.
But with video games you have years,
and years like pump yourself up,
for this game to come out.
- Cyberpunk hyping up right,
it was ridiculous.
- I am surprised though
that I wasn't expecting,
I thought I was going to
be the only Nintendo symp,
on this, at this table.
So I'm glad that you have at least,
like a couple of Nintendo games here.
- Okay, okay so let me ask you this,
was Wind Waker your first Zelda?
- It was the first Zelda that I finished.
- That's normally how it goes.
'Cause my favorite was
like Twilight Princess,
and I know that it's not the best one.
'Cause I think Breath
of the Wild is better,
than Twilight Princess.
- Yeah but Twilight Prince is
still a fucking solid game.
- But it's only cause I like,
I think that was the
first one that I finished.
And like, when you finish a Zelda game,
there's something about
it that feels like so,
'cause you were a kid.
- Yeah, I mean, I, it was
like really hard for me,
to pick between Wind Waker
and Breath of the Wild.
I was fucking obsessed
with Breath of the Wild,
when it came out, 'cause I remember,
when I started getting
into Breath of the Wild,
was the first time that I
came to Japan with Sydney.
And the first time I,
the first time I met you.
And I remember like I had
a great time in Japan,
first time in Japan.
Of course you're gonna have a great time,
but I remember no matter how many times,
no matter how many times,
I went to Akihabara,
no matter how many times
we hung out and everything.
At the back of my mind, I was just like,
I kinda just want to go home-
- I could be playing Breath of the Wild,
- I could be playing Breath
of the Wild, right now.
- Garnt in the club.
(laughing)
- Like, I'm just like, you
know, fuck Joey man like.
Come on, come on, Joey, yeah you're good,
but are you Breath of the Wild good?
I don't know about that.
- You could have said that to my face.
I would have been like, you know what?
I ain't mad.
I kind of agree.
I kind of have to agree with you there.
To be fair though,
I wasn't expecting
Sunshine for some reason.
- Okay, out of all the Mario-
- You don't seem like a Sunshine player.
- Why don't I seem,
like a Sunshine player?
- I don't know.
You just don't, you two don't
seem like Nintendo game,
I know, I know you're
not, but you definitely,
don't seem like that.
- I like Nintendo games.
- Because I think the only re,
the only Nintendo games that are on here,
are like my childhood
Nintendo games, right?
Because I was definitely a Nintendo kid.
I was such a Nintendo symp when I was kid.
I was like, I didn't, I never
owned any other console,
apart from the NES, Super
NES, N64, Game Cube.
And it was only after the Game Cube,
that I finally ventured out, which I,
which is why I just didn't own a Wii.
And I think since then the Switch,
is the first Nintendo
console I actually owned.
And so I still, I still would like,
out of all the Nintendo games,
these two pop out to me,
as the ones that-
- I think those two,
are the most popular.
- Honestly.
- Normie.
- It's like most popular 3D Mario,
and most popular 3D Zelda.
- I mean, I think Wind Waker is great.
I think you could, you
could put Wind Waker,
or Breath of the Wild as number one.
And I'd be, you know, I
can't hate on both, right?
'Cause I mean, at the end of the day,
- But like a lot of
people who grew up my age,
they put Ocarina of Time, and I-
- I'm not gonna lie, dude.
Not going to lie, I don't
understand the hype,
for Ocarina of Time.
- No, I played-
- Okay, okay.
I thought I was, I kind of
got bored of Ocarina of Time.
I kind of did.
- Well it's like, how like,
I think Wind Waker again,
it's slightly odd start right?
Wind Waker aged fucking fantastically.
Ocarina did not age well.
Like you play that shit now.
It is like fucking impossible,
to play that-
- Well that's,
that's what I'm saying,
like I've always said,
like Ocarina of Time
for the Zelda franchise,
is a lot like Final Fantasy Seven,
for the Final Fantasy franchise.
Where it's like, because
it was the first 3D game,
after a long succession of 2D games,
obviously when the 3D
like boom, was starting.
It was massive, right?
So people immediately
will like it's in 3D.
Automatically 10 out of 10.
- I also didn't grow up with it.
So, you know, I ended up playing it later,
even like now, right
to me when I, you know,
who I've played all the games
from Wind Waker onwards.
I just think like when I'm
looking at Ocarina of Time,
like you know, Majora's Mask
looks so much more interesting,
in like every single way
this game was fucking weird.
- I agree.
- It's so cool.
But like I-
- Did you ever play,
Majora's Mask?
- I did like about two
hours and then I was like,
fuck this is so hard.
- Majora's Mask is hard as shit.
- It's really hard.
- No, I would 100% prefer playing,
Majora's Mask over Ocarina of Time.
Just because like, again, like it's,
well I mean for, for one,
both are hard as shit.
- Yeah.
- Also,
I don't like playing it on the emulator.
I don't know why,
something feels wrong about
playing Nintendo 64 games-
- 'Cause I have Majora's mask on like,
cause I have like a proper N64,
and I have Majora's mask.
And it's like, I don't know,
the feeling's kind of the same to me.
- Really?
- Yeah, I don't know.
Maybe it's like
- I want, I want to go back and play them.
I do.
- But I, again, like,
I don't understand people who are like,
Ocarina of Time is the
greatest Zelda game.
I'm like, I'm sorry, it's not, it's not,
it hasn't, I'm going to get a
whole lot of hate about this,
but it's, the look,
I've publicly said that I'm sorry,
but Final Fantasy Seven is
not the best Final Fantasy.
- It's again, it's what
Cowboy Bebop is to anime.
- Right, it's like, it's the one.
- That's what it is.
- It's the one you probably watch first.
It's the one that probably
got you into the franchise,
or into the medium, right?
But that doesn't mean it's the best.
- Yeah, I mean, I agree,
because these might be the
ones from my childhood that,
you know, I have the fondest memories of,
but they weren't the first is Zelda,
or Mario that I played in my life.
- I'm surprised you didn't
have a Super Mario 64 on there.
- Here's, because-
- You're such a boomer, Garnt.
Hey where, these aren't
boomer picks, Garnt.
Where are you're boomer picks?
- These are way too new.
- Because the thing is,
I'm not like a super massive Mario fan.
I did, you know,
I have completed 64, completed Sunshine,
completed, what's the
most recent Mario game?
- Odyssey?
- Odyssey.
I mean, I completed them,
not got all the shiny shines,
or you know, but I got to the end game,
beat Bowser the final time.
So, you know, I have completed them,
but out of all the
Marios that I've played,
I just think there's something
about Sunshine, you know?
You know when you think back to a game,
and you just, it just vibes with you.
Like the feeling just vibes with you.
That's sunshine.
- I feel like Sunshine is just clean.
It's so goddamn clean.
- It's literally in the
name, Sunshine, okay?
If you couldn't tell I'm a
bit of a summer kid, right?
We've, we've had many
arguments about this,
where like, I fucking-
- Does that mean anything?
It does!
- Just because,
I like the winter, I'm not
gonna go get fucking Mario,
at the fucking Winter Olympics, right?
- He's playing fucking Mario 64,
gets to the snow level, turns it off.
- No, no, that is exactly who I am,
I fucking can't stand the snow level.
- But why, you guys call
me the monkey brain,
this man sees virtual snow.
- Are you playing Mario in like 4D.
Like.
- No, because like.
- Goes outside.
- Your on the snow level, turn on the AC.
- You know, there are
some levels out there,
where you hit it and you're just like,
Oh it's this level again,
like every fucking water
level in any video game,
of all time,
- No I get that,
but I'm not like, oh fuck,
you know, what's one thing
I hate about the stage,
the weather.
I've never been like that.
- I am literally like that.
- What the fuck is wrong with you?
- No, like when I played Mario Sunshine,
and like, I, I loved it,
because every level is like,
every level gives off that summer feeling,
and that summer vibe which I fucking love.
And it's like the, the ones that I hated,
the levels that hated the
most in Mario Sunshine,
were like the Boo levels,
something where it's like dark,
and scary.
- Not the pachinko level,
fucking sucks.
- Yeah the pachinko level,
is the fucking worst.
- But like for the most part,
it gives off a very summery vibe.
And I think back to that, I'm just like,
yeah, I fuck with this.
Imma use Joey's term
here, I fuck with this.
You know, I just, it just makes me happy.
It gives me the good feelings.
- No I get that, I get that.
- They're like, it's like so hard to,
this is gonna be such a
boring part of the podcast,
where we're just like, damn
Garnt, you have a good taste.
I mean like, this is categorically,
just two great games.
You know what I mean?
Like, congratulations Garnt,
you have good taste, all right?
- Oh God, oh God, I've become Connor now.
- What does that mean?
- But this is super vanilla.
- I mean, I'll happily say
that this is super vanilla.
- I mean, it's also just interesting,
because it's like, I think it's because,
we just never fucking talk
about the games that we're into.
So like I never expected like Subnautica,
or like Gears of War to be there.
- Yeah, what the fuck?
I love fucking Gears of War.
Why, why is it on your list?
What the fuck?
- Okay, so I had a hard
choice putting my, my,
my last three.
So Gears of War is on there,
because it is the first
multiplayer game, that's,
it was the game, that is on there,
because that's how I
discovered online gaming.
And I'm just like,
man, Gears of War was a
good fucking online game.
- No dude, it was clean.
And honestly, Gears of War two,
was probably the first
game where I was like,
whoa, video games can like make me sad.
- Wait, what?
- The story.
- Oh with the story.
- Okay. No, I didn't give
a shit about the story.
- The story's so good.
- I don't even think I finished the-
- Wait why am I, are we swapping here,
what's going on?
Bro, the story is so good.
- I literally put this on here,
because like I had had such a hard time,
'cause I'm just like, I didn't
give a shit about the story.
- No dude,
- If there's one thing I
remember about Gears of War two,
it's the story.
- Dude the story is so,
I remember that this,
Okay, it doesn't count
as spoilers anymore.
It was so fucking old.
You should know by now.
- What was the story again?
- The locusts are taking over the earth,
and your basically stopping
them, et cetera, et cetera.
I mean, that's basically like the-
- Wow. Gee whiz.
- Because there was like,
the two duo who you're
following, which is-
- I just remember one guy,
trying to look for his wife or something?
- Yeah but that was the part.
- That was the sad part.
- That was, cause then he like finds it,
but then he didn't find,
it was like an illusion.
And then I'm like, what the fuck?
I was like, I was like 13.
I'm like, I'm like what?
This is so sad.
- And this like fucking,
massive meathead of a character,
breaks down in the battlefield.
I'm just like, Oh my God.
- I'm always just like,
this is the first game,
when I'm just like, Ooh chainsaw
go (imitates chain saw).
- That's how it gets you in, right?
So Gears of War gets you in with the,
chainsaw go bruh, super manly man,
and then 10 minutes in
you're fucking crying.
And you're like, whoa, what happened?
- It's like chainsaw man, the game.
- For me, the one memory I
hold for Gears of War Two,
the multiplayer is just the sounds,
the sound it makes when
you pop a guy's head off,
with a sniper rifle.
Like I like.
- Did you play Gears of War?
- Yeah, I played two, yeah.
- Like that was, I
think that's sole sound,
and I don't know why it
was so fucking satisfying.
'Cause it was, it was like
literally cracking an egg.
- Well, I mean those, those,
those shotguns are like still,
there's like no multiplayer experience,
like the online in Gears of War.
It's just shotguns.
And like that's like the meta,
is like you have to run up to
people and shotgun each other.
- Okay, the shotgun was
also really satisfying,
when you got like a point blank
and the body just explodes.
My God, like I like,
you're the monkey brain,
but that was like the first time.
I'm just like, okay, I enjoy this now.
This is fun.
- It was really sad,
'cause I think Gears of War got plagued,
by the fact that there was just like a,
like, there'd always be like.
two really fucking God
tier players in the game,
that could just dominate the whole lobby.
So it just kind of became
not fun after a while,
if you weren't like a pro,
'cause you'd just get fucking destroyed,
by the like, good players.
- I def, I didn't play online
Gears of War Two a lot-
- It was really good online.
- What console was it on again?
- 360.
- Yeah, 'cause I didn't own a 360.
But I played it at my
friend's place a lot.
Just like lan multiplayer,
and that was like really, really fun.
But yeah, I probably,
from the sounds of it,
I probably wouldn't enjoy it online.
- No, you probably wouldn't now.
I mean, it w it was me discovering
what multiplayer meant,
and before I started hating, okay.
Gears of War started my
love for multi-player games.
League of Legends killed it.
(laughing)
- And yet it's in the middle.
- League of Legends is in the middle.
'cause I think out of,
out of all of these games,
I have probably played
League of Legends the most.
Not proud to admit it,
but the reason it's on
there is because I think,
the honeymoon period of
League of Legends for me,
was probably the best gaming
experience of my life.
- It was really long for me as well.
Almost like, like two years long.
- That's a long honeymoon.
- Dude, when you're
getting into that game,
and it's going well.
It feels so fun.
Like, it's great.
It's so fun to get into.
It's just, it's hard.
- 'Cause the problem is now I feel like,
multiplayer games just aren't fun,
unless you are getting into it,
immediately as it's released, right?
Because the problem,
the problem with multiplayer
games I've found now,
is that you have a new game
and that's, when a new
game just gets released.
That's the fun part,
because nobody really knows
how to be good at the game.
Everyone's just kind of like
really discovering what works,
and what doesn't, everyone's
just fucking having fun.
And then you get to a
point in multiplayer,
where people just realize how to,
optimize the fun out of the game-
- The sweaty boys come out, right?
- That's what happened with like Fortnite.
Honestly, like honestly all memes aside.
Fortnite was so fun
when it first came out,
there's a reason why it blew up.
And then when it got to the point where,
everyone would like
build a fucking mortgage,
right in front of your
eyes within 10 seconds,
and you couldn't do anything,
it's like, well, this
is just not fun anymore.
Like, I didn't have the
dexterity of like a Chimp,
on like coke right?
Like how am I supposed to do this.
- Yeah, 'cause I remember like,
I really, really fucking
enjoyed Overwatch,
when it first came out.
- Yeah me too, me too.
- Like and I never,
I didn't make the same mistake
of trying to do ranked,
because I'd learned
from League of Legends,
but even just playing casually,
I really, really fucking enjoyed it.
And then they got to a point,
when even in casual games,
you weren't allowed to have fun anymore.
You got the same or the
same, the same heroes-
- Can you change of Hanzo?
- I mean, I will fully admit,
I was like, again, Genji main,
because I was a dirty Weib,
and the reason I played Gengi was,
because I fucking sucked at Gengi,
but like the one, the one time out of 10,
where I did an ult and
it actually works out.
That was the reason I played Genji.
Like nine out of 10 times
I would complete flunk it.
I would fail.
I'll get killed straight away.
But that one time, that one
time when it worked out,
I, that's what I live for, man.
And because of that.
I was one of the most toxic.
I wasn't the most toxic ones,
but I was, I was that
one Genji on your team.
That probably threw you the match.
I was that, I was that person.
- Did you talk shit to your teammates?
- I didn't talk.
I'm not a toxic gamer funnily enough.
I'm just like, "Oh, come on guys.
"We can, we can do it.
"If we all put, all try."
- Go team!
(laughing)
- We can, win with the power
of friendship, come on guys.
- Oh my God.
In ranked, you had to get,
you had to start like shouting at people,
to get them to shut up.
- I'm just like, I'm just like that guy,
who just goes mute all and
just does my own thing.
- I do that sometimes too.
- I mean, I play it as closely,
as a single player game as I can,
because like playing
online games just makes me,
makes you realize how fucking,
how much I hate people.
- People are the worst.
- Especially in competitive ones, right?
- That's why Like in Japan it's so weird.
'Cause like people just
don't smack talk at all.
- Well they don't know how to.
- Yeah at most you'll
get passive aggression.
Like-
- I'd probably,
I'd probably enjoy Japanese
competitive gaming then.
- No one talks unless you talk to them.
- Because I play in the
League serves in Japan,
and like 90% of them
are just Chinese Smurfs.
So of course they're like
toxic as shit, you know.
- Yeah. That's why I
don't really play anymore.
'Cause it's just like you
can't fucking have fun,
in League of Legends.
It's just like a Korean,
Chinese playground,
where they're like, oh let's go,
and fuck, like fuck with
the Japanese players,
who suck at this game.
- Yeah.
It's it's literally just,
it's literally, it's just the playground,
where the school bullies go to,
to just like bully like the-
- It's like LeBron James
coming down to the elementary,
man, just to start dunking, you know?
(laughing)
- Just be like you suck.
- Yeah, you know what I mean, man.
But like, all right, Metal Gear, whatever.
I mean, that's good.
You can't, what can I say?
- Yeah, no one can complain
about that, honestly.
You can put any Metal Gear in there,
it would have been good.
- I mean, for me, like
do you know the reason,
I enjoyed Metal Gear?
- Why.
- Because I have played all Metal Gears,
except for Metal Gear Five.
Apparently the best one
in terms of gameplay.
- It is the best one.
- I have really no kind
of want to play it.
- 'Cause of the hype fatigue.
- No, no, not okay.
- I get it,
you feel like you've had your fill?
- No, I didn't have my fill,
like I was hype as shit for it,
- What is Garnt.
- Then I found out that,
the story was kind of like incomplete,
and I'm just like okay, well that,
that just takes the reason
for Metal Gear away from me.
- So leave it more
incomplete by not playing it?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What that doesn't make any sense.
- It's not finished and
I haven't finished it,
so I'm not going to do anymore.
It doesn't deserve my time.
- Okay like how how'd you, how'd
you feel about this corner?
Like when you play, have
you ever played Metal Gear?
- No.
- Okay.
- None of them?
- No, 'cause I, it was like, I dunno why,
but like I never really
saw it in like the shops,
when I was growing up.
- Probably 'cause it was also
on PlayStation as well, right?
- I had a PlayStation two growing up.
But yeah, for some reason I was
probably playing like Shrek,
and Spyro and dumb shit like that.
- Good choice.
- I was really like, yeah,
when I was, when I was younger,
I wasn't attracted at
all to like the FPS art,
or like the like military looking stuff.
Like I always went for the childish,
cartoonish looking stuff.
Even when I was like 14,
15, I would still like,
the prefer the cartoon anime style over...
So I normally avoided those.
So I was playing like fucking
theme park games and shit.
When I was like 15.
- Like Rollercoaster Tycoon and shit?
- Well the like
PlayStation, had it's like,
it's own brand of like
these theme park games.
And I think they're still quite popular,
on YouTube occasionally.
And you could like, you
could build the rides,
and then ride them from
like, POV first person.
- Oh wow.
- It was really cool.
- Shit.
. Do you know the one I'm on about?
- No, no.
I'm, I'm just getting a
flashback of memories, now.
Maybe I should have put that one there.
'Cause I've spent far too much time,
on Theme Park or theme, Theme
Park and Theme Hospital.
- Yeah, yeah, I think, you know,
Rollercoaster Tycoon is
like, (indistinct) love.
- Oh dude, I put way too much time.
- Honestly it could be on my list.
- Yeah, I'm just like, shit man.
Maybe I should have pulled down my list.
But yeah, in terms of like,
I never go to got into
Rollercoaster Tycoon,
because a Theme Park had
like the voiced person,
telling you what to do.
And I don't know something
about having someone voiced,
telling you what to do was,
was a big selling point for me.
- Was that the one,
the PlayStation two one I'm on about?
- Maybe, I dunno.
- I dunno about that one.
- I'll have to find the
box over winter break.
- Yeah, but, but it
definitely had a POV option,
where you could build the rides,
and then you could ride it.
- You could, and there was
like racing games in it.
So when you built like the racing track,
you built the track yourself,
and then you could race around it.
- Oh, that sounds cool.
- Dude it was awesome!
- Why have I never heard of this?
- And then like-
- Shit, I wanna play it now.
- There was like-
- Awe fuck.
- The normal park, there
was like an alien park.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You remember this?
- Oh fuck.
- And they,
each world had like different ride things,
that you could ride.
And like you, you couldn't
progress to the next world,
unless your theme park was X successful.
- That just sounds like
Rollercoaster Tycoon
- It is Rollercoaster Tycoon.
- It is like,
Rollercoaster Tycoon but like better,
because like Rollercoaster
Tycoon is pure like top-down,
and this was like, you get in there,
you can walk around your park.
That's POV, like it was so good!
- Why I'd never heard it.
- This is the box art.
I'm going to find it,
and I know what the box art looks like.
I think they released all
the types of games as well,
but it's the one that like,
I literally played to death on the PS2.
- No, you, you are, you
are reminded me now.
And I'm just like fuck.
I didn't play on PS2, I played it on PC.
- It was on PC as well.
- Yeah, yeah, it was on PC.
Fuck man.
(laughing)
That's the thing about memories.
- Nostalgia hitting me.
- No, because I fucking loved
simulator games like that.
I couldn't, I could
never get into the Sims,
but I fucking loved like
Sim City, Theme Hospital
Rollercoaster Tycoon,
not Rollercoaster Tycoon,
Theme Park as you said.
God, I put some many hours into those.
- Just hit him with that nostalgia.
- Aw this is why-
- So that's why, like I never
really played military games,
because I would always see like the,
like the bright, like boxes.
And I think I'm like, you know,
being a fucking 14, 15 year
old, you're like. (panting)
- No, I was exactly the same,
when like, when like Heavy Rain came out,
and I looked at the box art and I'm like,
what the fuck is that?
And now I regret not
playing it back in the day.
'Cause much, many years later I played it,
I was like, this game's fucking fantastic.
- 'Cause like, I loved
like Crash Bandicoot,
so much on the PS2.
And like, that was the kind of art style,
that I normally gravitated towards, so-
- Wow, completely forgot
about Crash Bandicoot.
- Yeah, right, right,
like there's so many
games that you've like,
even all the spinoffs of Crash Bandicoot,
like Crash Racing,
they had like the Mario
Party esque kind of game,
called like Crash Bash,
which I really liked as well.
- I heard of that one.
- Even though,
it's a terrible game right now,
but I used to play it a bunch.
And then it was like Crash
one, two, and then you know.
- Crash Racing, dude.
That shit was so good!
- Crash Racing is,
the only racing game that could,
legit compete against Mario Kart.
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
What was the,
Diddy Kong Racing?
- Diddy Kong Racing.
- Diddy Kong Racing is up there.
Come on.
- Really?
- It is up there.
- It's up there.
- I got Diddy Kong Racing for the DS?
- Nah, no, you need to play the N64 one.
- The N64 version,
because that was when he
could actually compete with-
- Well it was made by Rare, right?
So they probably, I could see Rare-
- I remember like 10 year old
me going to my friend's place,
and he had, Diddy Kong Racing on N64,
and I'm like, wait, you
can ride on airplanes?
- Yeah and like boats.
- What the fuck?
- Yeah, like for me,
I was really close to putting
Banjo Kazooie on here.
- Oh my God, another normie pick.
Normie.
- Normie, but it's good!
- It's good, what can I say?
And yeah, I dunno.
Like, okay so,
like a big reason why, that I
had so few games to pick on,
to pick from right,
was because when I really get into a game,
I really get into a game.
Like I wring out, as much content
as I can out of that game.
Every side quest, every
little piece of dialogue,
I play it to death, so
I can get everything.
Like with let's say, so with Metal Gear.
Right, so there would be
times where, you know,
are you familiar with the Codec calls?
- Oh they would like call
you up and be like, "Snake".
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
So, so one, one of the big
criticisms of Metal Gear,
when, you know, I was playing it.
And you know, when it was
like really, really big was,
people hated the cut scenes,
how long we cut scenes were,
people hated the fact that you had to,
go through all of these Codec calls.
I fucking love that shit man.
I'm like, I'm like, holy shit,
there's an hour cut scene?
Be right back getting the popcorn.
This is the most epic game
play I could ever hope for.
- Was Metal Gear Three the
one with like psycho mantis.
Is that the one?
- No that is, that was the first one.
- That was the first, was it really?
Oh I thought the first
one was like the top-down,
like NES one.
- Oh no, no, no.
- Oh that's, that's,
that's Metal Gear.
- That's Metal Gear,
not Metal Gear Solid.
- Metal Gear Solid is like the 3D one.
- 'Cause like every time I watch it,
'cause I've watched tons
of videos about Metal Gear.
And every time I watched it I'm like,
fuck I wish I like got
this when I was kid.
'Cause it looks bad-ass.
- It was fucking bad-ass.
And, but the thing, the
thing is like, okay,
so there's Metal Gear and
there's Tales as well.
Tales has this feature, right?
I mean, you've played the Tales game.
How did you think about the skits feature?
- What was skits? What was that?
(laughing)
- Okay, so.
- Oh wait,
is this where you talk with a character,
and it was a fire emblem thing.
- What?
- Wait what?
- Where you interact with
characters, is that what it was?
No, am I crazy?
- Kind of.
So in, in Tales games,
they have this thing called skits, right?
Where you'd be walking around,
and then you press like the select button,
when they give you a prompt, right?
And it would just be characters
talking to each other.
And-
- Oh yeah, I'd never,
I always skip that, didn't do it.
- So like I was probably
the one fucking person,
who just hit every skit button.
Like I don't care what, what time I'm in.
What like, at what point of the story.
I would just like, I
literally played Tales,
and I literally, like, there
are some skits that are only,
that only happened at
certain areas of the map,
which like some areas of the map,
you'd literally have to walk,
on the other side of the map.
And there was no like quick.
- Wow, this is a big boulder, huh?
Yeah, it sure is.
- It literally doesn't mean shit.
- Yeah, yeah and it
literally doesn't mean shit.
I fucking love that feature.
I don't know, man.
I like, cause here's the thing,
if I love the characters
and I love the world,
I'm getting every kind of like,
I'm getting kind of ever-
- You're interacting within-
- Every interaction I can.
Same thing with Mass Effect.
When people talk about how
much they love Mass Effect,
they talk about, oh you
know, the character writing,
and you know, the, oh not so
much the game play anymore,
but like the world and
the characters that,
of Mass Effect.
I was probably, I like,
I remember there was one,
Mass Effect game play session I had,
where I literally wasted an hour or two,
because in Mass Effect they have this,
it's not a Codec function,
but like a database function.
Where they literally have
a database of like every,
like the history and
lore of like every alien,
every world that you go to.
So I literally,
I literally spent an hour
or two of Mass Effect,
going through the entire
database and just,
and just reading the
whole lore of Mass Effect.
- I'd rather not, I'd
rather not, you know?
- And, (laughs), and
(laughs), I fucking loved it.
I absolutely loved it.
- I can't even shake my head,
'cause I used to do that.
- What's wrong with,
- Exact same thing.
- what the fuck is wrong with you guys?
You guys don't want to play a game,
read a book or some shit.
What the fuck.
- I did, I did that recently actually,
when I played Xenoblade
two for the first time,
and there's this, like,
there's this part where like
every monster you encounter,
has like a full page
about like how it lives,
and shit like that.
I read through all of it.
I'm like, Oh, okay.
So like the Zephyros
only lives in the swamps.
- That's, that's really interesting to me.
Like to me, that's what
really makes a video game.
Like it's, especially because,
if I'm like really into a video game,
I'm gonna find out everything
I can about that video game.
And that's like, but the thing,
there's a difference, all right, '
cause I like when it's just
fed to me in video games.
Like people have talked about, you know,
the lore of Dark Souls
and everything like that.
And people have like figured stuff out,
through the subtle hints,
that you get through playing the game.
I'm just like, just tell me it.
Just, just give me exposition.
This is the one time where
I actually want exposition.
- When you say that.
All I think about is the
I'm the Silent Hill person.
Who's like-
- Hideo Kojima
- No, no, no, sorry.
So there's like on Silent Hill forums,
there's like, where they discuss like,
what the game's about and stuff.
There was like a really big thing,
and a big like contra, well
not controversy but like drama,
because one of like the main admins,
who had like some of the most posts on it,
was like convinced that the
main character was circumcised,
and that was the reason
for his like trauma,
and that he was like gay or something.
And that he was gay because
of it or something like that.
And so there's this whole like,
dude like Whang made like
a 20 minute video about it.
And it's like this whole thing,
where it was like a
massive deal on the forums,
where they're discussing you know, is,
and then the guy was like, you know,
he was on like a crusade being like,
no one should be circumcised.
It causes trauma and stuff like that.
And it turns like a whole thing.
And I'm just like, this is what people do?
In my mind, I'm like, that's
people who read story,
that's what they do.
They go on forums.
Talk about why the main character's gay,
and his circumcision was trauma.
It's like what's wrong with these people?
Play a fucking video game.
Why, why are you typing about it?
(laughing)
- I'm not even surprised by that.
- Because yeah I, that's sort of like,
when you said, I'm relieved
when you like it being,
like the story being told to you.
But you're like I want to figure it out.
Is my, is my character
actually like gay or something?
Let me, let me,
- Is he circumcised?
I need to know.
- I need to figure it out.
They've left, Hideo Kojima left me hints,
That Metal Gear Solid
Snake is circumcised.
Like what?
- Which is funny like,
I'm more than happy to watch
anime where I'm just like,
Oh what's the subtle,
what's the subtext of this?
What is the author trying to say?
But with gaming, I'm just like, nah.
No patience, just give me-
- Well,
because you're already focused on like,
actually playing the game, right?
Where it's like, no, no,
I don't need to, like, I
don't want to like sit here,
and fucking guess what the story is,
while I'm trying to do this
convoluted input, right?
- And there's also another thing that,
also like, it's going to be,
it's going to sound super weird,
but sometimes I hate
choice in video games.
I just want a linear game.
Which is funny that Mass Effect-
- I was gonna say, you
literally put Mass Effect.
- The fucking Mass Effect.
- Literally Mass Effect Persona Five,
- But like yeah, yeah,
Mass Effect and Persona Five,
which are the two, like let's say the two-
- Choice, heavy games?
- Two of the most choice, every games,
and the two exceptions to
exceptions to that rule.
But I have, I have this thing,
I don't know if I'm the only person,
who has like gaming FOMO,
where I'm given a choice.
And I know that like,
by making this choice,
I'm going to miss out on a
certain piece of content.
I hate that.
I hate that so much.
Right, because that means,
that means in the back of
my mind, I'm just like,
but what if I pick the other choice,
and, and-
- Well, that's literally,
the reason why I replayed
Persona Five, four times.
'Cause I was like, oh
there's four choices,
and I want to see all of them.
So I'm going to play it four
times to get all the choices.
- I think it was unfortunate,
that I, I like swore off JRPGs
after playing Blue Dragon.
- Oh really?
- Which I mean, I think
I've mentioned this before.
- Yeah you've talked about it.
- It was the one that was like,
I think the main selling point
that comments were saying is,
that it was, the art was
made by the Dragon Ball guy.
- Yeah, Toriyama.
- Yeah and like,
I never encountered this
before in a video game,
and this is what really pissed me off,
because I at this point, I
was an achievement hunter guy.
So I would always go in like 100%,
I would get all, all the
achievements, no matter what.
This is the first time
I encountered the thing,
where I'm like, okay so this
story is two hours long,
or some dumb like that.
It's ridiculously long.
And I did it.
And then I'm like, all right,
how do I get these last few achievements?
And it'd be like, this achievement is,
on the forum it would say this like,
this achievement is only unlock-able by,
doing this one option in this one mission.
If you pass it, you can
never get this achievement.
And I'm like, what?
What?
It's just they suck.
- That's such a JRPG move.
- And that's so fucked up
that they would do that.
Like what kind of sick fuck does that?
Are they like,
I don't want anyone to be
able to get this achievement,
make them play the whole fucking
like 200 hour game again.
Fucking assholes.
There's no need to do that.
Why would you do that as a game designer?
- I don't know,
if it's to get you to-
- Assholes!
- It's to get you to
replay the game, right?
- Yeah. I mean, I-
- The fucking, fucking every time-
- I mean like the reason I hate it is,
because it takes enough energy
for me to finish a game once.
So I'm thinking, fuck if I
need to replay this game,
I'm just not going to see this content.
- Right, right, right.
- Yeah and if you want to see
the shitty turn-based combat,
you should play Blue Dragon, man.
Every time you start a battle,
fucking the muse, the
main song starts playing.
And it's a guy fucking singing.
It sounds like the Pokemon intro.
And then it takes like
20 seconds of animations,
where they all like summon their things.
It's like 20 seconds long
before you can even start,
the fucking turn-based combat.
- Dude don't tempt me.
That sounds awesome.
- Don't tempt me like that.
- Dude, I'm excited.
- No, it's fucking garbage, man.
- And it's Toriyama dude,
that is like right up my alley.
- Garbage.
I also hate in JRPGs, they
give you these characters,
and like, what if you hate the characters,
that you have to use?
Like in Pokemon, at least I can swap out,
you know Bulbasaur-
- No but like most JPGs
like it's, you know,
like especially with a
turn-based ones, right?
It's like, you can only
have four in the party.
So just pick your four
favorite characters, right.
- This one, it was like,
you only have these guys
and they were shit and
annoying characters.
- Yeah, so it was like what
am I supposed to fucking do,
this game sucks.
- Well then,
that's not a good JRPG, is it?
- And then like one of
the main enemies was just,
a snake coiled in like a shit.
And the whole joke was
there was a piece shit.
And I'm like, yeah hilarious.
- That sounds hilarious.
- What, it's a piece of shit.
It's a metaphor for the game.
I'm still annoyed about it.
I completed it and I loved playing it,
but I literally only played it,
because it was like, I bought this game.
My mum wouldn't buy me another one.
So I have to complete this game-
- I need to play this now.
- I want you to play it,
just so you can, like, reaffirm-
- How did you get that game again?
- So what it was is like, you know,
I didn't know if your
game stores had this,
but in the UK they had
a three for 20 pounds,
pre-owned games.
- Oh yeah, yeah
- So I would basically
just go to the thing,
and buy three games that looked okay.
And then I would just
be forced to play them.
And most of the time they
were all like super easy.
- And you had an absolute
gold, like Blue Dragon?
- Well 'cause there was
Like one of each game.
And there's a whole shelf of Blue Dragons.
Just like, take 'em, take 'em honestly.
Like for free, honestly.
Like it comes with the bag.
- Was it like, was it like
a well received game at all?
Or like-
- I think it was very,
mid tier, like it very like
five out of 10, six out of 10.
This was my first time
ever having to swap disks,
to progress with the story.
And that shit pissed me off.
- Holy shit,
- Yeah, I remember that.
- I just remembered something.
- What?
- All right,
Okay, I get rid of Gears of War-
- No, that was a good pick!
- That's a good pick.
- No, no, no.
- Get rid of Subnautica,
- Okay,
- Yeah why is Subnautica,
in there?
- I'll get rid of Subnautica.
I just remembered something.
Put FIFA 09, in terms-
- Get out, end the podcast.
What the fuck?
- I just fucking remembered.
I was fucking, I got, I was,
I had a period in my life
where I was obsessed with FIFA.
I am, I am not joking.
- Were you also smoking
cigarettes on a corner,
playing footy.
- Okay, this is, this is
during the university,
you know, you're, you're
in a British university.
Everyone played FIFA-
- I'd refuse, I'd be like no.
No I'm gonna play anything else but that.
Fuck this game.
- I just remembered something,
I was one of the top 200 players of FIFA,
at a point.
- (laughs) Really?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm
not joking, I'm not joking.
This is like just giving me flashbacks.
- This is like Connor coming out,
that he used to be like a college pro.
It's like Garnt used to be a FIFA 09 pro.
- So how were you, how
you were the top 200.
How did it work?
Is it like rankings or like-
- Yeah, it's like ranking
it's a literal ranking system,
and it got to the point where I was just,
I just got myself on the leader boards,
of a, of FIFA.
- I don't know how I did it.
- And because I was just
obsessed with the game.
And like everyone started playing it.
So I'm just like, oh,
I guess I'll play FIFA.
- Did you demolish everyone
in like your uni dorm?
- Yeah pretty much
Because see, because here's the thing,
because like my group
mates and my uni dorm,
they were like super, super
competitive over FIFA, right?
It was like-
- They were like that in mine.
- Yeah and this was how
you get bragging rights.
So there was two games,
it was COD and FIFA.
And I was just, to me, it was just like,
FIFA was not like
watching football at all.
FIFA was just like, (laughs)
ball goes, boop, boop, boop.
And, and yeah, I dunno.
I just got really good at it,
and I don't know how, because,
yeah I mean-
- Just the British in you.
- Yes.
- Oh yeah there was two games.
- 'Cause I fucking, I
feel like it was one game,
where I got good at
really unintentionally,
and it was probably the only game,
that I've ever played in my life,
that I got good at unintentionally.
And I don't really like
football that much.
- What's wrong with you Garnt?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
- I don't know.
- Top 200 in the world,
I hate this game.
- Literally like psyched 'em out,
I just need a worthy opponent.
- The fact is like I had
completely blanked that,
from my memory until just now.
- Like it's the shameful,
the shameful time we don't speak of.
- I'm just like, how the
fuck did that happen?
How the fuck did I get top 200 in the,
yeah top 200 in FIFA and I'm just like,
yeah I just played it.
And I just kept ranking up.
And then I just got really
bored and I stopped playing,
because, and the reason
I stopped playing was,
because I finished uni,
and I didn't have a
reason to play it anymore.
- Wow, wow.
- 'Cause I remember now how it started,
because I got the game,
literally just to blend
in with the normies.
So I literally got the game,
so I could have something
to talk to people about,
at parties, right?
And so.
- I'm one of them.
- He literally bought
FIFA as a social gimmick.
- Yeah, yeah so I started playing it,
so I could like keep up with
my mates and everything.
And then I just kind of
figured out a meta, I guess,
because you know, it's football,
everyone wants to score goals.
And then I quickly realized,
if you just learned how
to defend correctly.
And if you just could defend good.
You are better than 90% of players,
that ever played that game.
'Cause everyone already
wants to score goals.
And then so after that,
so I've, so after that,
then I figured out the broken teams,
and the broken team was Barcelona,
because they weren't the best
team in the world at the time.
But then so most people
were picking Barcelona.
And then I realized that there
was a counter to Barcelona,
which was Inter Milan,
because Inter Milan
had Zlatan Ibrahimovic,
and he just completely
destroyed the Barcelona defense,
because he couldn't be
shaken off the ball.
- That's the Swedish guy, right?
- Yeah, that's the Swedish guy.
He in the game, he was
completely fucking broken.
- So then in real life
he was completely broken.
So then once I realized that,
I just thought it'd like, just
started beating all my mates.
And then I was just like, you know what?
Let's just, let's just, let's
just limit, test myself,
how far, how far can I get up with this?
And you, I said top 200 earlier.
I'm not sure if it's top 200 or top 300,
but like one of the, one of the top,
- Still impressive.
- Yeah one of the top few
hundreds in the game at the time.
And I just kept, I just
kept playing until,
I stopped climbing.
And yeah, that's, that's
how far I climbed.
And then like, I just
casually told one of them,
one of my mates that,
and he's just like,
"Have you ever thought
about entering competitions,
"or stuff like that."
and I'm just like, no,
I don't think I will.
Because, because, yeah,
I just wanted to make anime reviews,
and watch anime at the time.
So I just like had no
interest in playing that game,
in my own, in my own time.
- Takes off Adidas, tracksuit.
Don't think I will.
- Imma hit the showers.
- And yeah, I just, I
just remember that now.
So I don't know what
reminded me of that topic-
- That was like pre the,
before the FIFA Ultimate Team, nonsense.
- Yeah. That was, that
was before FIFA Ultimate,
I don't know what the
fuck is going right now,
with FIFA Ultimate.
- Yeah, so like right now,
like I think if you want to have,
a legitimate competitive team in FIFA,
you need a team of a value
of around 27,000 real month,
like dollars.
- Jesus.
- That's how much you on
average have to spend,
to have an actual, like
top competitive team.
- Why?
- So all the pros have
spent like $30,000 plus.
- So okay, okay.
- Fucking hell.
- Just, just to compete,
- This is, this is
going to sound so weird,
after everything I've just said,
what's FIFA Ultimate?
- Basically they, you know,
again, this is 100% like an,
imagine an alien describing
how humans converse.
Like I've never played
this myself, but obviously
I'm a gamer.
So I like to keep up with games.
But yeah so essentially what
it is, is micro transactions,
like imagine anime, like, you know,
cause Fate, can you go
against each other in Fate?
Like PvP?
- No, no, no.
- So imagine a PVP Fate
where you can build a team,
just so happens that of like, you know,
two or three characters.
It's like a team of like
11 or whatever it is.
- So literally FIFA gotcha.
Well yeah, it's like,
they're the ones who like,
this is the reason why it started.
Like, it got so bad.
- Oh my God.
- So it's literally pay to win.
- It's a 100% pay to win.
And so like to even,
so to be like to be able
to compete competitively,
you have to have the stacked team,
to get the stack team
you've spent on average,
like $30,000 to even have a chance,
of getting the stack team.
- Dude, that's, that's fucked.
- It's so fucked.
And like you, you hear even
the pros talk about it.
Like there's interviews with
them where they're like,
yeah it's not fun at all.
Like you have to spend
this amount of money,
and everyone's playing the same shit,
because everyone has the same broken shit.
- Yeah, everyone has boss players.
- It's so fucked, like,
you know, we sit here and
complain about gotcha.
And it's like, yeah, okay.
You know, at the end of the
day, it is 90% of the time.
You're not, you're not
playing against other people.
And that's where it
starts to get real fucked.
- No, When, you start
playing against other people,
that's where , that's
where I draw the line.
- Because, because, because you're like,
Oh, I, you know, I could beat this person.
I could, I could have won this event,
if I just had that extra broken cactus.
- Because the way I see
it is that with gotcha.
With the gotcha games I play,
you're playing against a computer,
or you're playing through to get content.
If he comes, if it becomes PVP,
then you are kind of making
someone else's day worse,
by paying more.
You know what I mean?
- It's definitely,
- You're making,
you're making someone else's
gaming experience worse,
because you payed more.
And that's, that's where I draw the line.
- Yeah 'cause I used to, I
don't know which game I played.
I think I found it on like
Miniclip or something.
This is like,
when I first started earning my own money,
and there was like a game where,
it was kind of like one of those,
like you are kind of like,
what's that Clash of Clans,
like the really popular mobile game,
the one where you build your own fort,
on your square, the map.
And then people can attack you,
but it takes like days
for their army to arrive.
So this was like, before,
even that was out,
I was playing a game similar to that,
on like Miniclip or some shit.
And then like, I remember
I was playing this game,
and I thought I was doing pretty well.
I had only spent like 20 bucks.
And I was like, oh this is,
I'm doing pretty good for myself.
Hey.
And then literally like
a guy who had like,
the fucking like,
just perfect like Putin's
palace worth of shit,
just came in and just
one shot my entire thing,
that I'd spent months building,
just because he clearly was like,
he had like just oil money or something.
This man had everything in the game.
Which must've been like
50 K worth of stuff,
and just killed me.
And I was like, I was like, what the fuck?
What the fuck.
- Imagine Peter winning a Miniclip game.
- Yeah I know right.
- I was like, I felt bad
that I spent 20 bucks on it,
because I was like, I was like 18,
and I was like, oh my
gosh this' a lot of money.
And I was like, this asshole wiped out,
not only the hours that I put in,
but the 20 bucks that I
put in were wiped out,
and I couldn't fucking do anything.
I had to sit there and watch
his army coming for five days.
And then you can drop down
the menu, see this man's army.
The man had sent like the
equivalent of like everything,
they fought 300 against me.
And I'm literally like-
- Like the fucking,
Persian Empire.
- Yeah, I'm literally
there with like my fucking,
like Stickmen ready.
And I'm seeing this army
camp like four weeks ahead.
And I'm like,
fuck, okay.
Like mom, get the credit card.
Like what am I supposed to do?
This was so fucked.
And a lesser man would have been like,
I can win this,
a lesser man would have thought I could,
I could outbid this man.
- So this is why people
hate microtransaction.
I get it, now.
I understand games.
- I think from that moment on,
as I slowly saw that
man's army approach me,
the resentment built everyday,
to the point where I was
like, I can't, this is fucked.
And just watching my work be destroyed.
- So what, I guess going back
to the FIFA Ultimate thing,
I'm curious, like, how do
people even become pros?
Does that mean you have like a-
- You have to legit be good at this,
- Like literally drop
a house deposit, on it.
- You have to be good and
also have disposable income,
to become a pro in FIFA
Ultimate then I guess.
- Isn't it sad that when
you're going to a tournament,
there's probably some
people at that tournament,
who are like, need that money to recoup,
the money they put in just to like,
isn't that sad to think?
- Oh, that is, that is fucked.
- Like, you know, normally,
you know, if you're,
if you're an amazing fighting game player,
all you gotta worry about is
that the hotel getting there,
and you know, making sure
you have enough to live
which is all, okay,
which is difficult enough.
But you add on that of like,
oh sir, I spent 50 K on Peach,
like to enter this match,
you know what I mean?
It's like, this is ridiculous.
Like it's so bullshit man.
I feel bad for the like,
the people playing FIFA, who
like genuinely liked the game,
but have to deal with this shit.
- I didn't, I didn't know,
it had a competitive scene, at all.
'Cause I mean, I stopped playing
after, after like, '09, 10.
And I'm just like, okay,
that, that, that is behind me.
I literally blanked it from my memory, so.
- You got out, you got out.
- I got out, I got out.
- Yeah it's a good choice.
- Shall we move on gentlemen?
- We're an hour in, we
should get into another one.
- Let pull or Trash Taste Kuni in,
and see who's going second.
- Do you want to pick Joey?
- Sure.
Okay, next is Connor.
- Wow. We literally did this again.
We went in order last time,
do you want to put these two back in.
All right, pull mine up, put it up.
- All right.
- Check this out.
- I'm I'm ready for a lot
of toxic gaming right here.
I'm ready for a lot of pro gaming.
- I have reasons behind all my pixels.
And also I think some of
them you'll be like, yeah,
Some of them you'll be like
what the fucks wrong with you?
Here we go.
Look at this shit.
Check this shit.
Check this shit out.
- Okay. (laughs)
- Check this shit out.
Some good games.
- Okay. There's some here that I was like,
all right, fully expecting,
- Yeah fully expected
- Some of them?
Okay, I'm going to have
to give you points,
for the the middle three there.
- Yeah, bro, come on.
- Especially the very middle one.
I was not expecting from you.
Super Mario Strikers is like,
if you played that game as a kid,
you know, you're in the know.
- It is so good.
- It is legit.
Like it is an actual crime-
- FIFA '09 ain't got shit.
- Dude, Garnt was here being pro at FIFA,
I was here fucking clapping
my friend's cheeks,
with the super smashes.
Bro, Super Mario Strikers, right?
If you've played this game,
you'll know exactly why this is on here.
This shit is God tier.
Like everyone who's played
this game fucking loves it.
- It's the original Game Cube one, right?
- It's, yeah yeah, it's so good.
And it's an actual crime.
We don't have this on Switch.
- Have you, that it was that
one and also Sluggers as well.
The baseball one.
- So, oh my God.
Oh my God.
You just hit me with nostalgia.
- Sluggers, Super Mario
Sluggers on GameCube is so good.
- I had a fucking ordeal trying
to get Sluggers on the Wii.
- Oh really?
- So what happened
with was is that I saw
Sluggers somewhere online.
I was like, mom, I want this.
And it was only available
from like Taobao,
or something on China.
Like, so my mum bought it from China,
for me for Christmas.
And it was like the one game,
that I really wanted that Christmas.
And I put it in.
And then obviously the, Wii has that,
what's it called, region lock,
- Oh the region lock yeah,
- So I put it in and I was
like, why isn't it working Mum?
And obviously my parents
have no fucking idea.
And they're like what is this,
- We bought you the game.
- This is, it's the game.
Why isn't it working?
And they didn't figure it out either.
So they sent it back,
and bought another one from China again.
'Cause for some, some reason it didn't,
it wasn't out in Europe, for some reason.
Think either, it hadn't released yet.
'Cause you know, back then it was like,
for some reason they
would leave six months.
between the release and the European-
- Europe and Australia were
always the last ones to get.
- Yeah, it sucked 'cause
you'd have to see,
all these YouTube videos.
You're like I know this exists.
Why can't I buy it?
And so I had an whole ordeal,
and I never got to play it in the end.
Even though we bought
it two or three times
- I play sliders at my friend's place.
And I had the most fun I've ever played,
in the Mario spinoff game.
- I think.
- What is Sluggers?
- It's the baseball one.
- It's the baseball one, okay.
- I think that Mario Strikers,
is the best Mario spinoff game.
- Well Strikers, there's
Strikers, there's Sluggers,
and then there's Mario three
on three basketball as well.
On the DS, do you know that one?
I never played that but it looked good.
- I played that, dude legit-
- I feel, I feel like you're just naming,
Mario Party mini games, now.
- Dude, honestly, all of the
sports spinoffs of Mario,
are all such fucking solid games.
Like Mario Tennis, fucking solid,
Mario Golf, fucking solid.
- I think I legit would put like Strikers,
like up there with Mario
Kart, like main line.
- Yeah I would too.
- I think it's that good.
Like to me it's like, yeah, okay,
of course I like Sunshine, Garnt.
Of course I like goldens game.
But like Mario Strikers,
that's when you're woke,
you're like, I'm listening.
Like if your mates like,
you want to play Strikers?
You're like, fuck yeah dude.
Cause it was always like,
you know, are they, you know,
cause there was this mechanic,
and it was probably the funnest
mechanic in a Mario game.
Where like, you, so your team,
would be made of two
main Mario characters.
So you'd have like, you
could put like Waluigi,
and then you'd have like four Koopas,
or four Birdos or whatever, right?
And then he could pick like Wario.
And so there's this mechanic where,
you could choose to do a super shot,
with the main character
if they had the ball.
And it was basically
like a quick time event,
and he'd just nail it,
and like the perfect, like the, like the,
be like an arm that would swing to hit it,
in the perfect zone.
If you've got it perfect.
It would be a guaranteed goal.
So it was always a thing
of like, Holy shit,
can he do it?
And it was so hard because
the timing is super fast.
- Yeah, it's like tiny, it's fucking tiny.
- And you have to, I think
it's not even guaranteed,
unless you're past the halfway point.
So you have to be past the
halfway point to do it,
and yeah, it's fucking, it's so good.
- It's so good.
- It's so fucking good, dude
- Do you want to go through
your three by three.
- Sure, sure, so.
- Okay, okay.
I gotta ask first.
- I know, I know which one
you're going to ask why?
- What the fuck is Battalion Wars?
- Okay, all right.
- I've never, I've never
heard of that before.
- I've heard of it.
- I've never even heard of it.
- Dude, if you look up Battalion Wars.
It's like one of the
highest rated games on,
like the least this one is on the Wii,
and the first one is one
of the highest rated games.
Dude it is like a really
fucking good strategy game.
So it's like, so I
really liked the online,
where it's kind of like,
it's got, really hard to explain.
- Is it like tanks?
- No, so it was basically
like you'd be given,
like a set amount of army.
So you'd be given maybe like three tanks,
four long range tanks, 10 ground units,
and there'd be a mission.
And so the, the way
that it worked is like,
you would have to try and take
over, or take over a base,
or push, push the enemy
out without losing,
as many people as possible.
But the online was really good,
'cause it was essentially the same thing.
But one person was defending a point,
and the other person had to
push and it was really fun,
'cause I got really fucking good at it.
When I was like 15, I
would just keep winning,
and I would like cheese
people with strats and stuff.
It's such a good game.
I played so fucking much of that game.
It's so good.
- Because I've never
heard of this game, right?
And I look at this cover,
and I'm just like this looks like,
some Chinese knockoff game.
- No dude, dude!
- This, this is like the,
"Mom, I want Advance Wars."
The mom goes, "We have
Advance Wars at home."
- Can we zoom in, can we zoom in on this.
- Nah, this is the most zoomed in.
- Really, fuck.
- Oh okay.
- Dude, Battalion Wars is legit.
Like a good game.
- You can see, you can see
the cover here right now.
- Dude it's good, dude it's so good.
Checkout game player of it man,
- Cause I'm just like genuinely curious,
why I've never heard of this game before.
- It's kind of like, I don't
know how to explain it.
'Cause it's like, it plays
somewhat similar to Halo Wars,
but quite different like,
Oh, that's it as well.
So I completely forgot,
one of the main mechanics of the game.
So imagine a real-time
strategy where you can be like,
give me first person control of this guy.
I'm going to fucking get on
the ground and do the work.
So you can swap between the units,
if you're doing first person.
So 'cause sometimes obviously
the automation is like good.
But you can obviously be
way more like in control,
and do more damage.
So like the, the like, you know,
'cause there's tanks, there's planes.
That's whatever, like
the planes were okay.
But if you went first person,
you could really fuck people up with them,
and you could dodge shit way
easier and stuff like that.
Dude. It's so good.
Anyone who played Battalion Wars Two,
will know it fucking slaps.
- No, no, no, I'm not, I'm not laughing.
I'm just realizing that we went through,
my entire three by three
talked about it for an hour,
and not once did I use
the term mechanic, at all.
Gameplay mechanic.
I'm just like, oh yeah, gameplay mechanic.
That's a selling point to games right?
Didn't, didn't mention that once,
throughout my entire three by three.
- One thing that's going to be definitely,
I guess throughout all
of my nine, is that like,
I really think they have like super,
like strong game mechanics.
- No, no, I, I look at this
and I'm just like, yeah.
A lot of these have really
strong game play loops,
like Guitar Hero, fuck of course.
- Like I, you know, me
music, isn't my thing.
I like, I like beeps and
boops, but Guitar Hero Three.
I played the fuck out of that.
Trying to get like,
- I think,
everybody who had that game
played the fuck out of it.
Legit, I can't remember
the amount of times,
I attempted "Through the Fire and Flames",
and like, just to like
think that I was good,
and then watch someone on YouTube,
like a 10 year old crush me at it.
- Perfect at it yeah.
- Because that was
always the game as well.
Like no matter what person,
like, if they were like,
I'm not into gaming,
it's like, no, no, no.
I've got Guitar Hero, they're
like all right, I'm down.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And so that was,
just like such a great game.
And also I really value being a game,
that is so good at getting
people who don't game into it.
Like I think, that's so underrated.
- I mean, who doesn't
game nowadays though?
- Well, I could get my parents,
to play Guitar Hero with me.
- True, true.
- Which is like, think of
how many games you could,
like I'm not gonna, my
parents don't wat to play,
fucking Battalion Wars Two.
How do I?
Yeah, yeah dad, okay so what you gotta do,
is you gotta take first
person control of this plane.
And then you got to push for the base.
No, my dad's gonna be like fuck off son.
If he sees me clapping
cheeks with this guitar,
he's going to be like,
I want to try that out.
And he did.
And it was great.
It was the one time
where you could be like,
my parents give a shit about my hobby.
But they don't.
- They're just like, I'll
humor you for a while.
- Okay, but the thing is, did
you own Guitar Hero Three?
Okay, because like I-
- Only one guitar though, I
couldn't afford a second one.
- Cause here's the thing, like
I love playing rhythm games.
I love playing especially
when we're at the arcade,
and everything like that.
I love playing rhythm games,
I've always loved the feeling
of playing rhythm games.
I've never like gotten to
the point when I'm like,
okay I'm going to own a rhythm game now.
I'm going to practice a rhythm game now.
- I mean, when Guitar Hero was out,
man they were like, they
were fucking everywhere.
It was so easy to get like,
knock off Guitar Hero ones and stuff.
Like, it was like, before
Rockband came along,
is when the hype started dying.
But like, it was everyone had Rock,
Guitar Hero.
- Guitar Hero, yeah.
I'm sad, cause like, I feel the fact that,
I started learning how
to actually play guitar,
kind of threw me off playing Guitar Hero.
'Cause like I would like
watch people play Guitar Hero.
and I'd play it as well.
And I'd be like, this is really fun,
but I could also just be playing a guitar.
- Yeah well its probably the instrument,
for people who don't like instruments.
- Right exactly, so.
- And even now,
like I still enjoy watching like that,
Twitch streamer, who plays Guitar Hero,
custom songs.
- Acai?
- Yeah, like I love like
everything about guitar,
just seems so fun.
It's great, I mean, I think
it's a banger, honestly.
- Why don't you learn guitar then?
- It's fun.
- What? What?
- Learn guitar.
- I fucking hate instruments.
(laughing)
- Like, imagine that-
- How do I get points?
Where's the score system?
How do I get ranked?
You know, like it's none of those.
- It's like people who play sports games,
hate playing sports, all right.
- Well you know what
other, other rhythm game,
could have been on here that I,
I didn't play the rhythm game,
but I played the other game
of it was Donkey Konga.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Basically Donkey Kong,
the Donkey Kong bongos on GameCube.
- Jungle Beat, right?
- Jungle beat.
I thought it was way better than the,
the actual rhythm game was game one.
Cause they had the rhythm game one,
which was like,
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But then they had like a platformer,
that was using the bongos.
Did you see this.
- No.
- Jungle beat was fucking awesome.
- You would like platform
and then like you would,
like so if you clap it a certain thing,
and then if you hit both,
it would do a certain thing.
It was so fucking cool.
- It was literally,
replacing the controller
with like two bongos.
- And it played so well,
like you think it wouldn't,
and then sometimes the,
the boss fights were like,
fucking clapping battles.
It was so cool, man.
That the game was so good.
That could be on here as well, but-
- For me it was like
only that one rich kid,
who had that game and everyone was like,
wait you have it?
All right I'm coming over.
- Well, that was cause like I played,
the rhythm game one at my friend's house,
and I was like, mom, please
get me this for Christmas.
And then I like, at the time I
kind of already regretted it,
because to me, it was like I paid like,
three times the price of a video game.
But just one game and it was good.
But I was like oh it's over now.
- Because for me it was a choice between,
Jungle Beat or Tyco.
And like, I got Tyco obviously,
because it was like-
- It has more replay value.
- It was more for me.
- I think my problem with rhythm games,
is that I have a hard time looking at it,
as anything, but a party game, right?
And because like, I, I
understand people getting,
getting into rhythm games.
But I can not play a rhythm game,
for more than like a few songs
before I'm just like, okay.
- I can, I can play for a while.
- I can play for a while.
- I really like,
I think one thing that
rhythm games, I quite like,
even though I don't like instruments,
or care about music much
is that I really liked the,
you can always like feel
like you're improving,
when you replay a song or like
when you're going through,
you always feel like you're improving.
- I'll tell you what,
like rhythm games are.
It's, it's feeling, like
playing an instrument,
without going through the boring parts.
Like, like my God, like imagine, imagine,
if you could just learn
how to play guitar,
without having to do scales.
- It's like, wait,
there's only five buttons.
That's so easy.
- You mean, I don't,
I don't have to like
practice scales five times.
Like, like five times every time?
- One rhythm game, I didn't
put in my three by three,
I could easily put it on there is,
Rhythm Heaven, you know that game?
On the DS.
I played the fuck, .
I played that game so much,
that I snapped two DS stylists
while playing that game.
- Holy shit.
- They can snap?
I didn't know they snapped.
- Yeah because I was like so
fucking concentrated on it.
That like, I literally was like, (grunts)
there's a crack-
- You're DS is impaled.
Like the stick comes out the other side.
- Legit I played,
like the reason why my original DS broke,
was because I played
too much Rhythm Heaven.
- Oh my God.
- Because it got to the point where,
like my touch pad was
like you've damaged me,
like so much so that the
inside is just fucked now.
And nothing responded.
- It's just like, your DS is just like,
the anime character who's just like,
gone through hell and just has been like,
battered and bruised.
- No dude, my DS like the touch panel.
My DS just looked like Bucky's body.
It was just like fucking,
it was just like shattered.
It's like this guy's been
through like a thousand wars.
- Your DS probably had so much gunk in it.
- Yeah, ah dude, it was fucking horrible,
but oh my god, I had so much
fun playing Rhythm Heaven.
- Any other questions.
- I mean, everything.
- Sonic Riders?
- Yeah Sonic Riders.
- Listen I know this is
going to get flack, right?
I'm surprised this isn't
the immediate thing,
that I was given flack for, right.
- I'm just shocked, there's
a Sonic game on here.
- Honestly, like I didn't give you flack,
because I was actually really close,
to putting Sonic Adventure Two, on my-
- No Sonic Battle Adventure Two?
- Yeah something like that.
- That was, that was that
easily could have been on here.
- Running around at the speed of sound.
- Just for like me, like me, like giving,
like my chows like steroids,
like dog, fuck in there,
drug him up do the race.
I loved that.
That was so fun.
Yeah, I mean like Sonic Riders,
was like the one game that,
cause it came with my Game Cube.
So when I bought the
Game Cube it was when,
it was already dying,
and they were just literally,
trying to sell it with anything.
So I got like a bunch of
free games with my Game Cube,
for like very cheap,
and Sonic Riders was the
one that I hated most,
that came with this game.
I was like, I was like,
these controls suck dick.
- It is one of the most jank Sonic games.
- It's like, so fucking jank, right.
And like the, the learning
curve for this game,
the mechanics seem
completely like overkill,
for like a kid's game.
But then after like, I actually sat down,
and like just for like 20 hours,
didn't understand the game,
and like eventually
understood what was happening.
This game felt so fucking clean.
Like it felt so good.
- Yeah I felt that way with
Kirby's Air Ride as well.
'Cause like first like
10 hours, I was like,
wait it's not just a racing game?
What the fuck is this?
I have to like earn my
ride and then go into,
- Right, right, 'cause there was like,
this like glide mechanic.
When you had to like jump,
into the other person's like trail,
and it was completely janky.
And it would like throw you out and stuff.
And it was hor.
It was so jank, but it was like probably,
the one game where my
impressions on it completely 180,
after I like actually put time
into it and got good at it.
And I was like, wait, this
is a fucking clean game.
And I played it so god damn much.
I played this game so fucking much.
- Just glad to know that
I'm not the only one,
who has like a 3D Sonic game,
as like a guilty pleasure game.
- Dude yeah, it was a good game.
- For me it was Sonic Heroes.
- I know Sonic Heroes, I
could have put Sonic Heroes.
- And I didn't put in my three by three,
just because like if I did,
I know people will be like,
you put a 3D Sonic game.-
- No dude, dude, I could put Sonic Heroes,
and I'd defend it.
- I have no like fond memories
of any 2D Sonic games.
It's the 3D sonic games,
I have fond memories of.
- I remember I tried to-
- Look there's one reason,
because I was Nintendo
kid through and through.
So Sonic wasn't available
until the Game Cube, okay?
That's why, that's why .
- Sonic Riders is a good game.
If you learn it.
Listen, like if you watch people
play it for the first time,
they'll be like, this is fucking garbage.
This is the worst game ever.
But then you see someone who's good at it.
You're like damn, that looks fucking good.
No legit, it's a good game.
- No, it was a good game.
I played it.
That's why I'm glad to know that.
Like I'm not the only one
who's like, you know what?
There are good Sonic games out there.
- I'm sure, Sonic
Heroes, if I replayed it.
Probably jank as fuck.
- Oh yeah, I'd probably
hate the fuck out of it.
- And like, I remember that casino level,
I fucking hated in that game,
but I enjoyed Sonic.
I remember you just keep dying randomly.
From stuff in that cavern.
- It was one of the most.
It was a shit game.
- I don't think I played Sonic Heroes,
but I've definitely played
some 3D Sonic games,
and I've actually enjoyed most of them.
Okay what else we got?
- I mean Black Ops is self explanatory.
- Black ops two that is.
I think I, even though I played like-
- I couldn't tell you the difference.
- There's a big, there's
a massive difference.
Okay. You know, if any, you know-
- Which one's the one
was literally starts off,
with the airport, getting shot up.
- That's Modern Warfare Two.
- K, never mind.
That's my extent of
knowledge of Call of Duty.
- Dude when that came out.
That was such a big deal.
- Oh yeah it was a huge deal.
- My mom, like she'd
already bought me the game.
And then she was like, Connor.
I've heard about this thing in this game,
where you can kill a bunch
of people in an airport.
I didn't buy you that game did I?
And I was like, no, no, no.
You didn't buy that, you
didn't buy me that game.
She was like, okay, good, good, good.
And I, no Russian.
So yeah, Modern Warfare
Two is the one that,
I probably played the most.
Modern Warfare Three,
is one where I won a bunch of free shit.
And then Black Ops Two,
was probably the one I had most fun with,
and that I played competitively
like in teams and stuff.
And I really enjoyed.
It was so fun.
It was so clean.
That game, they like optimized it.
It was like the best COD, a
hundred percent hands down.
The maps were the best.
The multiplayer had
like a good rank system,
which they'd never had before.
I don't think they ever put back in,
like it was legit, good.
It was such, it was just
a fucking great game.
Fantastic fucking game.
Anyone who likes COD will tell you,
that Black Ops Two is the best game.
- Yeah, that's, that's what
I hear, most of the time.
It's like, it's either Black
Ops Two or Modern Warfare.
- You're like, this is all noise to me.
- It's all pew, pew kill a guy.
Is this how it feels
when we talk about music?
- Probably, probably.
- I'm like, I'm like, cool.
Has it got the pew, pew?
- It's the most (indistinct)
it's just a great game.
- It's just (mimics a
machine gun) the game.
- I put way too many hours.
And it's what got me into
like competitive gaming.
And I like really, that was
like the first e-sports ,
I started watching.
I just had like a really good tournament.
But then all the fucking pro players,
were like weird as fuck at that time.
They were just like, yeah, it was weird.
It was very strange.
- And then I'm not surprised you have,
Time Crisis and Metal Slug in there,
because whenever we go
to an arcade together,
and you have Metal
Gear, or not Metal Gear,
sorry Metal Slug or Time Crisis,
Connor's like all right, see you later.
- Yeah. Metal slug.
I've always just been
obsessed with metals.
Like act like acts is like
the best game overall.
If you don't know what metal
slug is, it's Neo geo game.
That was really popular in all K.
And you can probably still
find it in a lot of arcades.
It's aged.
Super, fucking well.
- It looks so good.
- Like the Sprite work on it
for its time was like insane.
Like it looks amazing.
- It still looks insane,
to this day.
- and it's got like some
of the best fucking sound effects.
The rocket launcher.
I love that fucking effect.
- Missile.
- I love those things.
You always hear those things
at gaming con dot exe.
I love those grenade.
Like so good.
Like the gameplay is
so clean in that game.
It doesn't overstate.
Its welcome.
It's like his six levels.
Enjoy them.
Get the fuck out.
- Did you ever enjoy Contra?
- Contra was really fucking difficult.
- I mean it was that's yeah.
- I think that the
reason why I don't like,
I think metal slug three
is like pretty one-
- It's way to hard?
- is that like, it goes
from like, you know
level one and two of metal
slug, three from being, you know
a fairly challenging game
to like level I think four
five and six just being
absolutely fucking stupid.
- I mean, I remember the first time you
and I have like game
together, we played all three
of the middle slot games
back one game session.
It's not long it's one and two.
Especially if with two
people who've played the game
you can easily breeze through it.
And then we got the three.
Yeah. And we were like, this game.
It's so hard.
- There is, it is
like you have to play that
game every absurd amount.
Because even if you know what
all the enemies are spawning
and where they're coming from,
it's like, it doesn't matter.
Cause there's just so much.
Literally.
It's complete.
I just did it just to
with you and take your money.
I just realized they should
have been another game
when my three by three
- We're talking about this, a mega man X.
Oh my now I'm thinking about,
I was thinking like scholars.
I, I completely forgot how
much I was obsessed with sites.
I was tossing up between mega
man X and make men too, right?
Yeah. Just purely man.
X is just them.
It's it's like, it still feels like anime.
Right? It's got a, it's
got such an anime storyline
but my God like the game
plan that is clean as well.
I forgot how much I loved
hard games as a kid.
And I really out.
I was like, Hey, cause I'm like, man.
Yeah. I remember I completed
Contra super contract lease
on the snares without that.
Without Contra code.
Yeah. Without the consequences.
And my cousin I'm call gamer right now.
I'm just like, I remember
fleeting mega man.
And that was really easy.
What the?
Yeah, because I was exactly the same.
Like I haven't beaten Contra
without the country code
or like I remember like how easy it was
for me to beat like mega man two
I could be going to like
an hour and like, you know
I think last year or the
year before I was like
I want to stream some retro games.
Oh I'll play mega man too.
Because I played that like crazy dude.
I got like 30 minutes in.
I only beat like two like robo balls.
I'm like, this game is impossible.
How did I beat this as like
a 10 year old patients?
Because go for it.
But like stuff with like country
- I never played as a kid.
So when I play now and
like just pull kills you
because there's a lot of.
Like yeah.
I'm just immediately
turned off from like that.
- This is just.
It's it's it's weird
because I I'm just like have
this conversation has
brought back so many memories
about how, how much
patience I had as a kid
because I remember another game
that was, people complained
about being super hard and super.
He was battle toads.
I'm not, I'm not sure it
was the level with the bikes
right? Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. I, I still remember
that level with the bikes
and having to complete that
and completing the battle toes.
And I'm just like, man, I
remember, I think I just
blanked it out because
there was just so many hours
of my life.
That was just some level.
And I just, as a kid, you
would just mind numbingly
just like learnt it through,
through muscle memory.
I would not have the
patience to do that anymore.
Like if you value your time
you're like, if there's some battle toll
- By the belt battle
toads, let's be honest is
- Full of.
But I loved that game as a kid.
Cause you can't, you can't
play that now and be like
this is fantastic Ninja
Gaiden for me as well.
That, that game is just
to where it's like, Oh
I remember I almost
beat that game as a kid.
And I got to like, I think like the second
to last level now I kind
of get past level one.
Yeah. And I remember like,
I'm trying to think back.
How the did I beat mega man X
on the snares control?
Oh my God.
I remember getting like cramps
and carpal tunnel from like the like
like tapping the jump button
on the wall, like right.
- No, it's better than mass control.
That thing was awful pointing.
- Yeah. I just think for me
- Slug is the best age.
Just a best overall.
- I think, I think it's easily.
One of the, one of the games
that's like age is the best.
I feel like
- Look at any like any indie
game that comes out now that is
like a side scroll, a running gun.
It's just, it looks so
inspired by metal work.
It's like identical.
Like, yeah.
It's, it's like the blueprint
of like, this is how
you make a clean running gun.
Like it's, you know, metal slug, you know
three is, but like one, two, an X, X
it's just kind of to
like one, two and acts
like I would highly recommend getting X.
I think it's on steam one and two also
- On steam, but like, don't
- Get it.
It's such a fun game.
It's just great.
It's like play with someone else, right?
Yeah. It's so fun.
It's so different to as well.
So it's just a great game.
I mean it's clean.
Yeah. And I'm wondering crisis, man.
Okay. I'm like the original one I think is
such a jam of a game.
When you go to NACA, do you seem
- You still think time of crisis is good.
And the only reason I could
never progress too far
in time crisis was because
I never had enough money.
Yeah.
- Yes sir.
Like I think once you get
over that point of time
crisis where you've beaten it a few times
you can beat the whole game
at least game one on one credit
like pronounce it pretty easily
because you know, you know
when all the coming and to me when
I used to play, cause
like, you know, when you're
when you would go to an arcade, right.
Cause we, I would stay
in like France for like, I
don't know, two weeks at a time.
My parents can be like to yours a day.
Maybe if I have
- Did you complete the
game the first time?
Which is what I want it I'm like
no matter what I have
always run out of money.
Yeah. I feel, I feel
like the first time
you played time, crisis
if you only had like two credits, right?
Yeah. You could maybe
get possible, you know
maybe up to like stage.
- So this was like a
something over like
years where it was like
I would always like see it
in arcades and I would always pick it up.
And then maybe if I have two weeks
I would play it like
every day for two weeks.
Right. Or I would like,
you know, and as well
I got to the point where
it, when, when, okay
if you had your name on the
high school, all of them.
So I would go and try and take
all 10 slots when I would go
when I would go to like a vacation
because I would be there
for like two weeks.
So I'm like, Oh, what
I'm going to do is I'm
going to take every
single slot in this thing.
Yeah. But then, and so
eventually what you could
what I would do is that that would be like
if someone was going to
play it, I would just like
I would just chill
out and I'd be like, Oh,
that's me, by the way.
And then they would be like, Oh
- Oh, they were, they would be like, Oh
you want to play with me?
- I'm like, hell yeah, give me a credit.
And they they'd give me a credit.
Right. I could just play
- You literally game the system.
- . Cause some people, some
of the systems when they
pulled out the plug at night
like it would wipe all the high school.
That was like my worst nightmare.
Cause I would, I would get the
high school feel real good.
I'd come back the next day.
And I'm like, where is it?
- Whereas my high school,
my street cred gone.
Just like that.
- That name was you though.
That's what I want to know.
People just took your word for it.
- That's a good question.
How did I do?
I
- Guess it's just the old system
right? Of just people just took your word
- For it.
I guess the old system
- I put the coin in
I started just destroying everyone.
They'd be like, I think it's him.
- I see you.
This is the old speed run rules.
Right? It's like, you don't
need, we don't need video proof.
We trust the juice
- Because like, if you're a
rookie, right time, they'd go
like this.
You know, I would just
like, so I would like get
- Like
- And then like flick
it off like that in time
crisis. Right.
- Cause the way I learned, right?
- I'm like, wait, the
normal way of shooting.
So if you I'm sure, I'm
assuming most people
who are watching this have seen
will play at a time crisis.
If you haven't, it's the one
where you put your paddle
down on the thing and
then you pop out to shoot.
That should be enough to let you know.
I mean, I assume if you've left
your house binge and arcade
or anything even been bowling,
you've seen this thing.
It's crazy
- Please. The best all came arcade game.
You can play, you don't live in Japan.
Or
- I realized right after
a while, I'm like right.
If you're doing the whole like holding it
with two hands pointing your
finger, isn't fast enough.
And the way the time crisis
worked with points is
that you had to, like, there would be this
like a smash combo.
Right? But when you shot a
character first, there was
like a split second where
you could keep shooting them
with bullets to get more points and combo.
So if you shot someone
once that's it, you can get
like 10 points.
You could unload like eight
bullets into one person.
So what you'd have to do is
when they would all pop up
on screen, you have to
get like maximum points
on each person on screen.
So I wouldn't load the whole
mag into one character.
So that's how you had to be
like, not just like discover turbo mode
- I literally
- Just learned the technique
of like spanning this thing, like this.
I was like, switch my
hand suddenly like, Oh.
And then I would do for
everyone on the screen.
And so that we, no one came
close to beating me in school.
Yeah. And then I would remember
the points where I like
I think a time crisis, one or two
there's a point where
you get a machine gun.
And if you, you could
like juggle the cover
so that you could keep your
combo even while going in cover.
So you could like juggle
it to get an absurd combo.
This man at age 10 is optimizing.
- So I remember this
- And like literally like age
13 and then like, it was like
- Maxing time crisis.
Loved
- It. And then, you know
then you start playing
time, crisis three and four.
So two was nice too was when
they introduced like, sorry
am I going too in depth?
So Tom crushed, this one,
all you had was the pistol
and you could just boom, 10 crisis two.
They started introducing like weird
like machine gun, grenade, shotgun.
You're like, all right,
whatever cool time guys.
There's three is where
they start getting weird
with it.
And they start introducing all this dumb.
Now we're on like seven garbage
like it's game where you just get shot.
It's like, it's like, how should the dead?
Well, you were playing five the other day.
And you said five was all right.
It's okay.
But like they introduced,
like they, I feel like they
they did what house of the
dead did like warehouse
or the dad was an amazing arcade game.
One was pretty challenging.
Two was quite difficult.
And they started adding a
few things that were like
that's true.
That's cheeky.
That and three onwards,
they just start adding
that would just kill
you unless you literally
like perfect headshot
because you've played it.
Right. And this time
is a, you're literally
hitting everything on how
should the dead and then
was just like just dead.
And it's like, this game sucks, Dick
this game.
You just took my money.
And I don't like it.
I'm a good pillow.
Literally. You'll literally
that kid him, you know
in persona five, you know
the kid in the arcade
like teaches you the gun moves.
That's literally, I'm just sitting here
and I'm just thinking, I don't
think I've heard Connor talk
more passionately
about something like, since I've been here
- I also had it on.
- So that also helped him.
Wow. That was the next day job I had.
I had time gracious too on the PS two.
And so when I went to the
arcade, I was like, it's just
like the simulations
then waiting to use that
- Meme. It was
- Literally like that.
Cause I was like
I already know exactly
what is the optimization.
I know all the levels off by heart.
- Well, there's a thing as well.
- Cause you were like
you were broke and you
didn't have credits.
I would legit, like I
it was the same thing with metal slug.
I would be like, I would
just go up to the kids
and I'm like, Hey, I'm
really good at this.
If you give me a credit,
I'll help you get ready to
and then you're like, Oh, okay, sure.
Cause then it was a win-win
because even though I
was doing all the work
they felt like they were
getting an extra 15 minutes
of fun where they would've got to.
Yeah. You know what I mean?
- I mean, that's, that's
the thing right away.
No, I mean, I guess arcade games or
whether your original
pay to win because I had
never met a single person who
had completed time, crisis.
Cause how the does any kid,
my age complete timeframes?
- I would like, I would like
to have a fit in my head
if I even got hit once in
time, crisis after a while.
Cause I was like, I knew
where they all should be
- Becoming this man's friend.
No hip time
- Fun. Cause I, it like,
like you said, right?
You're not supposed to
the games weren't designed
for you to play at this much.
Yeah. Yeah.
This is also why they
started upping the difficulty
of arcades because people
would just sit there all day
and complete games on $1
get 30 minutes when they should've
been getting two minutes.
And so that's why they started upping.
You know, now it's like
all the arcade games
like even the ones that used to be
like pretty fad used to feel good.
I'll just pull.
Like yeah.
Like the Mario kart arcade game now it.
That scheme sucks.
You get one race and it's it's.
You know like if you were doing
like Daytona back in the day
if you were good at that
game, you kept together.
You kept playing because you
kept getting to the points.
Right. But now it's like,
you get one race off.
That was $3.
It's like
- No, just, just cause you got to take a
- Picture with me and
put it on the character.
You think that's enough to keep me happy?
Oh off Mario.
- Yeah. Although to be
fair, every time I see that
and I'm with like three
other people, I'm like
they always want to play a game.
You play it.
And then every time you play
it, you're like, all right
people want to play it
because it's Mario cards
and people please worse
than the actual Mario.
They do that.
It's supposed to be better.
What the?
I'm so passionate about
because arcade games suck.
Now the fall of arcade
games, there's some good
the rise and fall, absolute state.
- You spoke about it on the podcast for
but typing of the dead.
And I hope it, I think I hope it isn't
in the one that closed down
because one of the game centers
in AQI Habra closed down and
only one of them had typing
of the debt because you've done
a lot of typing of the net.
It's Google it.
Yeah. That's good.
The Jojo battle.
Royales okay.
It's like, it's like a, it's
like an unreal engine mod.
It's kind of.
There's no real arcade games.
Knacks. Oh we can Mac one.
We've been spoken about that.
- we don't know what it's
called, but here it is.
So we don't want, it looks like you get to
- A Mac.
Like you literally sit in the cockpit.
Yeah. Put a seatbelt on.
And there's like gas pedals drift.
- Yeah. And it's like four D cinema.
So it would actually, it moves.
It moves as you are flying about.
So you are literally as close
to a Mecca pilot as you can possibly be.
And it's got ranked PVP literally.
- Do you literally like
you all jump in the mechs,
with the boys,
and PVP against other flare
really captured the flag
and it's like domination for Cod, I think.
Yeah. And yeah, you
literally like, it's so fun.
Cause when you smack down thrust and drift
- Pedal the chat jumps back jumps back
- Then it's like, yeah, like what's it
like when a chain's going
up on the roller coaster
- Did you, did you like drifting,
like drifting in the end?
Just flowering myself at
the same time with the boys.
Whenever you load the other
one, as you knock it off
this player, come to their pen.
You've got to chase.
This is like everyone says rhythm games.
No, this is the best arcade
game I've played in Japan bar.
None. I believe it's is it Sega?
I've only seen it in a
few are like sort of round
- And Sega, but like, yeah.
It's actually insane.
I think it's is it $2 or $3 a play?
- Not enough play.
I think one play can cost you, you know
like 15 minutes, 15, 20 minutes.
I'd happily play like
pay like five pounds.
If it was like in the UK.
Cause my God, you get to pilot a Mecca.
So cool.
- I don't even know
what's going on so I can't
read what the the they're
saying like I love it.
It's so fun.
- And I can read what they're saying
but I didn't give a.
It's not important to me.
All right.
Before we move on.
So okay.
Like I, I like, I I'm wondering why.
Okay. Before we get tailored ones
I'm wondering why you put
apex over, over league.
All right.
Okay. Is this recency bias?
- There's definitely been a recency bias.
I dunno for me, Leah legends
was fun and I really, really
really enjoyed the time I had with it.
And it could easily be on here.
Yeah. I think apex is on here just
because like our apex made
learning Japanese fun for me.
Okay. Like, isn't that
isn't that fun because
you're actually using it.
Right. And like, for me
apex has been such a door
opener like right now.
Like it's just like, everyone's
playing apex right now.
And like it's so easy
to be like, yo play PAX.
Just jump in.
Yeah. Like I dunno, just anyone it's like
especially Japanese or like V tubers.
It's like, yeah, let's play apex.
Let's do it.
Let's chill out.
I dunno.
It's so fun.
And I feel like it's, it's like
even though I just started
playing it recently
I have been playing it.
I did stop playing it at launch.
Right. And I feel
like the game's only gotten
bigger and better now.
And I feel
like that's raw for games,
especially battle Royale.
Like I feel like it's more
popular now than ever.
- Yeah. And I would say that and it's been
- Massive in Japan.
Yeah. Yeah.
VG was man.
They, they just broke the system.
It's crazy.
I mean, you know, it's,
it's crazy seeing how
like when it came out, you know, the story
of apex is that they, they
literally announced apex legends.
I don't know if you knew this
a day before it came out.
Oh.
Really? Because what happened
was is that it made was made
by the same people it's tightened full.
Right. So EA thought,
it says published by Ja
but it's made by respond.
The people who made Titanfall,
who made call of duty
modern warfare two back in the day.
So you have that, you have that
clean FPS gameplay combined
with a naughty movement of Titanfall.
And yeah.
So what happened was is
that they literally were
just like, Oh, by the way
here's a new bottle way out
because they thought it was going to bomb
because it was made
by the same people who had made Titanfall
with no Titans in it.
Yeah. And everyone was
like, yeah, I'm not playing
that where the max the
maximum, the best part.
Yeah. But yeah, no, it was
a surprise hit it blew up.
The gameplay is so clean.
- I mean, I've liked from what I heard
apex was just better Royales
but just with every mechanic refined
- It's so good.
It's so fun.
And you know, it's really like weirdly one
of the most beginner
friendly battery, I was like
- Yeah. Well, what I want
to know is, has it gotten
to a point where
everyone's just really good
at the game yet there's a
Metta and everything's broken
- Good. The matchmaking
is surprisingly good.
Like when I play ranked,
I really struggled like
against people, my own level.
When I go in like normals, if
I'm like playing with someone
who's like got a really bad
stats to like, even as out
like, I can feel like a God
but you know, so like in other words, yes
Yeah. I play with some
people who are like, you know
arguably have no hands
and they seem to have
the time with that life.
And I, you know, to me, I
would be like, that's not fun
but they seem to, you know,
they like, again, people who
you know, cause it's such
a position, heavy game.
It's not about mechanics.
It's more about do like, okay, are you, if
are you standing out in the open
and someone else is on the
high ground shooting at you
you'll probably going to die.
But like, you know
you don't need to have like aim God CS go.
That's like, I hate that.
Fortnite felt like that as well.
I feel that like, if you
just have like some form
of game knowledge, which you
can easily learn, you know
it's easy and all the
characters are already unique.
It's really fun.
Like, I don't know.
It's great.
I really think you guys should try it out.
Try it out with me.
Apex trash day stress.
- Literally every episode,
every episode it keeps saying
- Trash tastes apex when it's good.
Like, and legit
like I've made so many new
friends from it and yeah, like
Like I said, the other day I actually met
up with people who I met up on apex.
I met on apex, two Japanese
- Guys spent the whole night trying to
- Talk. Japanese is
very like taxing my God.
I realized I was an hour
into talking only Japanese.
And I was like,
I gotta do this for like
another four hours of like
not being able to communicate.
Yeah.
- It will do wonders though for you.
- I feel like I definitely
have like the basics
completely locked down.
Like it's all muscle memory.
Like I could just say, just talk nonsense
and big, you know, all the stuff you need.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. It was fun.
You know, it was just crazy to think
that I met these guys from just chatting
on a video game, literally just going
into the lobby and
screaming, broken Japanese.
And then I was hanging
out with them, you know?
Yeah. It was just chill.
Like it's all about the friends
- You know, I honestly can't
say about league of legends.
- You made friends from
legal legends, but like
it just felt like
- Oh, I can't imagine making
a friend from a guy you met
in a lobby and illegal legends.
So I bought that's the thing.
It was
- Good friendships with
them, like with age with it.
Cause it was always like
we were the same rank
we played rank together
and it's always this
weird thing of like that
that was what it was.
And we were like, we, our
friendship was tangential
on the fact that we
were both the same brand
and we were good enough to play together.
But in apex it's like, ah,
you know, I, I, you know
I play with a guy who is called Killshot
he's like a 45 year old man.
Right. Like West Japan, who's awful
at the game, but he's, he's really funny.
And so like, that's like,
you know, I like playing
with him just like there's
no, it feels chill.
It's a really chill game
but it can be a really intense
game if you want it to be.
And it's like, perfect because
it has like enough Lowes
in it where you can just talk.
And then when the moments
where you're like fighting
it's like right.
It's focused on fighting.
So that's why it's on there.
I legitimately think it's
the best battery I've played.
I've played so many of them.
It deserves to be on there.
It's a great game.
Play apex legends.
And finally halo Wars.
I'll quickly talk about this.
I played, I've probably put
more hours into any game here.
Halo was a part
of the game I put most hours
into really why halo Wars?
I don't know what it was.
It was ma what made me fall
in love with RTS is that game
was terribly unrefined and
and awfully unbalanced.
- I've never played Wars
but that's all I've heard about that.
It was like extremely unbalanced.
- It was the case of
I was very fortunate that
my, my fault, like I had
I had three best friends
and we all loved halo Wars.
So it was a case
of every single day we just
went home and played halo Wars
and it was just like the
perfect game to chat to
and also be like, you
know, do this, do this.
- Yeah. I really liked
the idea of RTS games.
I like, I mean
I remember playing command
and conquer so much.
That was my, that was my RTS game.
But I like, I've never
got into RTS, like more
than just build a bunch of
soldiers and then click on
click on anyone who looks at you.
Funny. That's like my
tactics when it comes to RTS.
- I think the one thing
that I really loved
about hail Wars is
that it really did two
V two and three B three.
Well, I can't think
of a single RTS game
that has three V three
like the new name.
It's always one V one.
And like, I find that like boring
like the fact that I can be there
with my mates and we
can all back each other
up and then like you kill one dude's army.
is his friend's army
is literally coming to
wipe you out.
- Then you're like, bro,
bringing your mommy.
What the?
And actually sounds really fun.
Cause that's so I guess that's
the reason I never played PVP
in any RTS, even though
I know there is there
I just played the
campaign and I'm just like
I can complete the campaign.
- Like, and it's a chill game.
Cause it's like
the games would never more
than 20 for 20, 30 minutes.
They were normally 15, 10 minutes.
So it was great because what
would happen is, is like
you know, there would just
be moments where you'll meet
or there would be like all three
of them would be attacking
your mate and none
of you are ready and you're
like, yeah, I'll see ya.
- No, I'm, I'm just realizing my, my
my three by three is a lie.
Why is red alert?
So you're not on my come command
and conquer red alert too.
That's a amazing game.
And not many people.
- I remember it was pretty good.
It's on a, you play on PC.
It's pretty good.
- Now the civilization
games, RTS like turn base
it's like almost turn base on it.
- like crazy back in the day.
- I feel like it's in the category.
The category was like a different style.
Like I play civilization
every now and again
because you know, when
you get that feeling
of just replaying a game
every now and again.
So I get that with save
sometimes and I'm just like
I play one game and lost
it lost like eight hours.
I'm like, okay, that's that
that that's that's my one out
the window now I'm satisfied.
Yeah.
- I see halo Wars is a great game.
I'm sure if anyone played it,
who like played it with mates
I love to play in RTS.
That's like two feet.
- I'm down for halo.
yeah. And it runs really well.
I've gone so many games that I just I'm.
I know I'm going to go home
today and be like, okay
I'm downloading all of
these games now time to
replay all these 27 days or
we should do, we should all do
- As a day where we all just say like
let's all play each other's
like choice of game.
Yeah, we should do that.
That should be fine.
We'll do it.
We'll just stream it all
be a whole day thing.
Yeah. All right.
- Yeah, sure.
All right.
Careful. One of the naughtiest dude
I mean you've already had my three by
- Three. Okay.
- There you go.
Okay. Okay.
Okay. Let me ask shocked by any of them.
So you're like a death
below, like completely
normally then you haven't
gone for final fantasy seven.
Well, no, I think six is like the
the second normal choice Terraria.
I didn't know.
Terraria was like up in your top night.
Okay. Terraria.
I've dead us.
Like if you go on
- My steam, I've played
Terraria for about 500 hours.
I was so insecure when I first came
out. Like
- Okay. Yeah, I'm done
talking about the son of five.
- I really need to talk
about breath of the wild.
Obviously. Why should Marywood
out of all of the murders?
Super a wall for me.
Okay. Because a lot of these games, like
especially the older ones,
like cubbies nightmare
and dreamland and final fantasy
six and stuff like that.
I got them as hand-me-downs
from my cousin.
- So like basically all the super Nintendo
- Games and like especially
Kirby games, especially.
Yeah. All hammy downs
and super Mario Wald was one
of the first like Mario games.
I like properly sat down
knowing it was a Mario game.
Yeah.
- Like, you know, there's like
games when you're like really
- Really young where it's
just like, this is just
a video game, but I don't
know like what this is.
It's just a fun thing.
That's on my screen.
Kinda. Yeah.
But super Mario Wald was the one where
I was like, okay, I'm playing this
- Knowing fully well that
this is a Mario game.
And that I love Mario game.
- It's literally like one of
the best games of all time.
- It's one of the Fest platforms.
Like it was a tie between
Sumara Walt for me
because we can only choose
one game per franchise.
Right. So obviously for
a Mario game, hottest
- For me to choose.
But it was a tie
between super Mario
world and Yoshi's Island.
Oh, Yoshi's Island.
I love you.
I was like, both of them are
like equal number one for me.
But I, I GN top games of all, honestly
except for Joey's like
individually clarinet
for me was just like, okay
that's what I'm like really
sold me on like animating
out of everything on here
that like, well, will I
that will make it known
that it's a Joey list.
It's clan out.
- If you remove that, she have no idea.
If you removed
- That, it's like, Oh
I see you were also born in the nineties.
- It's like, you've typed in top, top, top
top game, boy game, top NSN S game.
And then you've been
like, I'll have those.
I love those.
Wait, wait.
Which, which Mario is
it where there's like
there's a level where it
- The sun trying to kill you.
That's my brother's story.
I had nightmares of that.
- Really? That song.
I couldn't beat it.
And I kept, I kept having nightmares.
I'm trying to kill that level is hard.
- Have you guys ever played
the original merrier?
Yeah. Okay.
I think I've actually
played every mainline Mark
- intend to rereleases it every year.
Just pay me 10 bucks for the same game.
- Okay. Did you play as a kid?
Yeah. Okay.
As a kid, did you want to eat the shock?
The bricks?
Was that just me?
- But like, yeah.
As a kid, I remember I have
- This thing's memory of
just looking at the bricks.
I'm just thinking, man,
those look delicious.
- They kind of looked like shocked.
- I hope you didn't say that out loud.
Cause your parents were like, Oh God.
Oh.
We should take this game away.
- All right.
That's just me again, my life.
- Right. I think my three
by three is a little bit
of a lie because there's
a bunch of games on here
because to me, I was like,
okay, for me through and through
I was always a Nintendo SIM Nintendo seem
from the moment I got my
first game consult to today.
But because of that, I feel I've kind
of put too many Nintendo
games on my three by three.
I mean, I mean like it's, it's, it's
it's the first thing that
came to your mind, right?
Yeah. But I would, okay.
There's one game that I would pull it
on here on the X-Box and a
that's a team called SSX tricky.
- game
- Sixth street.
Okay. For those of you don't know
this is extra snowboarding game.
Right. And it ha did you
play snowboard kids as
well on the, in 64?
Was that just me?
- Oh, I played a little bit of that.
I played a little bit of that.
I think
- I think it was the first time I saw
as a sixth street because
I think my dad got it
because like my dad was the
one who bought the X-Box
because he wanted to play it
like a bunch of like racing car games.
And one of the racing car games
that me and my dad bonded
over was burnout three.
That's amazing, which I would also put
on my three by three
but like he also brought home
this game called SSX tricky.
I'm like, I never cared
about snowboarding.
I didn't know what the.
This thing even seen snow
live in Australia Legit.
The first time I ever saw snow
it wasn't necessary Played it.
And the moment you hear
that title screen music
I was like, hell
- Like to me, I'm just getting reminded.
But
- SSX tricky is on like the same level
- As Tony Hawk in my mind
- In terms
of just addictive gameplay
with Tony Hawk's pro skater
- Too. I haven't played
any of these games.
- So I don't know.
I think the one thing I optimize the out
of SSX because it was
probably the one game where
I was like, no, no, no, this
isn't the perfect score.
I know I can fit one
more trick into this, Joe
when you're addicted to a game, it's like
I know I could fit like one more
one 80 into this like
trick combo on this one.
And I would just keep playing this over
and over and over and over again.
I think I a hundred percent of it actually
it was probably one of the
first games, a hundred percent.
I think I was close to a
hundred percent in it as well.
I mean, all of these games,
I have a hundred percent
especially in terms of like Pokemon silver
the original silver,
it's the one game where
I've actually broken
the end game time off.
Like I played so much of.
- Right. Yeah.
How'd you do that?
- The end game time of the
Maxine game time as 999 hours.
And that's reasonable,
which is reasonable.
It's like a thousand hours.
Right. But the only way I achieve that is
because of like, you
know, obviously you play
through the game and
then you're like, okay
well I finished, I've
gotten all 16 badges.
What do I do now?
Yeah. Complete the decks.
Okay. I'll do that.
What's the step after that
get every Pokemon to level a hundred.
Okay. I've done that.
Right. Get all the Chinese.
- And I did that.
I did that.
- I did that to myself
because at the time, right
I was borrowing my friend's GameBoy Cola.
Right. Like we kind of like, this was
during the time where
like I had like a couple
of childhood friends,
like lived nearby where
we met each other often
enough where it's like
can I borrow you in 64?
Or can I borrow your super
Nintendo or whatever?
Yeah. So I never actually
owned the game boy color.
And, but I had Pokemon silver.
I don't remember where I go to from
maybe I borrowed it
from a friend that again
probably like probably
something like that.
But like I borrowed the
game book enough times
where I was like, and
it was the only game.
And also Silva was the
only game boy color game
I had as well.
So it's like, whenever I sold the gamble
of college was sitting at my desk.
I'm like, Oh, I mean
I can just play this,
going to kill some time.
And as a kid, you know
you have no concept of time
as you're playing a game.
Right. So it was like,
so yeah, I just was like
well literally got nothing
else to do other than
I guess I'll just try and
catch all the Chinese.
And I did that.
And I was like torture.
And I maxed out the in game clock.
I was like, Oh, 999 is the max.
All right.
I got it.
Now. Jesus Christ, Joey,
I'm telling you, like
you think you'll like, you
know, God thinks he's like
you know, once you're into a
game, you get addicted to it.
I get no, no, no
- No, you do.
You're you're on another level.
And like Kirby's a nightmare.
- And dreamland was the
first ever game I owned
because the gateway advance
was the first console.
I think I've played that game.
I've never played a single Coby game.
This game was the game
that got me to Kirby.
And I, since then, I love every Kobe game.
And like
- I'm telling you, like,
if you're ever feeling sad
- Just play a Kirby.
- It might be the most like childish.
- Like I'm gonna prescribe
you a copy of Covey's dream.
- Like literally, like you
might think it's like childish
- And Dom and like easy or whatever
- But it is literally
impossible to play a Kirby
- And not be happy.
- It's just the challenge.
Except there is, there's
something about speed running.
There's something
about it where it's like,
yeah, I might be in the
- mood and I'll play it
like 30 minutes of any Kirby
game immediately happy.
Right. And like, I think
that's why I liked playing it.
Cause I was like, I don't want
to play a game that makes me
- I mean, later on
in my adult I was like, yes,
heavy rain, metal gear, solid.
Give me all of that.
Yes. I would like a bit of
depression and, and I think again
- And that's another reason
why I like played a little
like animal crossing, for
example, or like, you know, again
like Pokemon it's like
you put animal crossing
in like the top nine in your life.
Yeah.
- Because like this one
in particular while, while we
had honestly wild wild world
- Specifically, because I
was obsessed with the DS
and this was one of the few
DSPs, this is the D S one.
- I hit a lot of like,
you know, now that now
that people have like calmed
down of an animal crossing
the first one, I've heard
a lot of people being like
you know, it is good, but
just feel like it's lacking
in a lot of ways.
And that they're adding
in the functions that were in
the previous ones literally
- Add-ons that they currently had on.
This is going to sound.
So Doug boomer or not, not boomer
but like what is the
point of animal crossing?
- Yeah. I mean, I feel like
- I'm trying to understand
why there's like
anti-vaxxers when I'm watching that.
I like, I hear, I hear what you're saying.
I get it, but I'm seeing it and I'm like
I don't get it at all.
- I totally get people.
Which is why I was really shocked
at how popular the newest one got.
Yeah.
- Because to me, animal crossing
a lot, like harvest moon.
Yeah.
- I always thought was
like that one niche series where it's like
if you want into it from the beginning
it doesn't matter how many
new games they bring out.
You'll never get into it.
I mean like the more people talk about
- I'm just like
well, this is just a pay
your mortgage simulator
- . And I'm like, okay
so you go hit that rock and
then you get some stones.
Okay. And then you go and talk to a guy
he gives you a recipe for
something that you didn't want.
And then you go and make that thing.
And it's like a cabinet
that you might not need.
And then I'm like, yeah.
- And then are confused
and they don't want to, you can sell it.
Everything is just seems so
- Slow. And of course it's an intender
so is just unnecessarily
complicated and convoluted.
Like I saw someone going to
like someone else's Island
and it took like a minute
of like cutscenes to go to
someone's Island or something.
And then like, everything
just seems slope in it.
And I was like
- I think that's the entire
point of animal crossing.
It's supposed to be slow
because it's not supposed to be like
- Oh wait, I hate games that make me wait.
Like
- Oh, it's the slice
of life of video games.
A hundred percent.
It is crossing Sims harvest moon.
See, I get all like, like
I get the Sims though.
Right. Because you're kind of like
you're kind of trying, you, you
you're kind of like
living a life that maybe
that maybe you couldn't
like live in real life.
It's really weird.
I never got into the Sims.
I never going to see the
SIM Sims is really boring.
Yeah. Now we'll cross this kind
of thing is I've really
liked simulation games
but I've never like never
a life simulator game.
I've always liked, you know,
why I never go into the Sims.
- Cute. Honestly, I understand
that you will get harvest
- Moon. You look at animal crossing.
You're like, that's a dog.
- I was, I was never into Sims.
But like when I started voice acting
and it's a weird tangent
like I started seeing Sims voice
acting project, everywhere.
People making their own movies in Sims.
This was a huge thing like Machinima.
Yeah. And I was just like, what the?
This is ugly.
And it looks dumb.
And it's like the animations
of Sims, like yeah.
And then they would, you'd
have to like voice back to it.
And I'm like, I'm not
auditioning for that.
What the?
- That's part of the like old age
of the internet campiness to that.
I feel like it has its own charm.
Yeah, absolutely.
- Oscar worthy drama performed via SIM.
And it's like, what the?
- I think that's the whole appeal.
Right? Because when animal
crossing first came out
I think I've read this somewhere
and correct me if I'm wrong internet.
But I think the whole appeal
of animal crossing was it
was supposed to be marketed
towards Housewives in Japan.
Who wanted something to do
as you know, their husbands
or significant others
were out working all day.
That's literally how they
market it because it was like
it was a non challenging game.
Not literally, it was like, it
was a game where it was like
- Are you tired of being
in the kitchen all day?
- It's like, because it's,
it's so not challenging.
And also it's, non-stressful
either, it's like
it's a game that like literally
gets all your stress off
because you forget about
everything in the real world.
Yeah. Well you can just focus
on a completely separate
just there are no stressors
or no, I guess like
bad things to happen with like
any consequence whatsoever
in this world.
It's literally Nintendo was
like, I'm a create a distraction
for stressed adults and
call it animal crossing.
Because I remember my
first and only experience
with animal crossing was
the original animal crossing
on the game cube.
And the only reason I
knew about it right was
because I don't, I think for
the longest time, it just
wasn't available in the UK.
Like it was only available.
Like they translates
there, but it was only
available in the U S
and I had about it from
- Like this Nintendo gaming, PC
their gaming magazine, gaming
magazine, gaming magazine.
That's what I meant to say,
this Nintendo gaming magazine.
And they were like, it just
got like super good reviews.
And I'm just like, Holy
this must be a banger of a game.
Every review is giving us a source.
Every review stimulus
five five-hour, five.
I'm just like, Holy, this, this, this
this is a musket game.
Why is this not available in the UK?
So I literally had to like look
up some like impor websites.
And like, I seriously, like I
had to import animal crossing
from the U S by like a
specialized import disc where like
because yeah, because old
GameCube games will region loads.
So you couldn't just put a
U S disc into a UK device.
You needed a special desk
that you needed to insert
into the game cube to, to region unlock it
so they could put animal crossing into it.
So I had to research and do that
to do that by myself with
a very limited budget
because I didn't really have much
of a budget to work with
back then, but I, I had saved
up and I brought animal
crossing and I was just like
this is going to be an amazing guy.
- This is going to be an amazing game
- This game, which is
expensive to import a game.
And I bought like extra
hardware on top of that
just so I could play the game
because every review said it was amazing.
Yeah. And then I started playing it
and I'm just like, that's
the gameplay kicking.
- I was like, okay, this
is an awfully long copy.
- Okay. I was picking apples.
I'm just like some, I'm just,
the gameplay is going to kick
in sometime, or I'm going
to have a point to why
I'm doing this.
Cause I expected it to be on
the same level as like Pokemon
- Or something like that
when I'm catching stuff
- Or I'm like, I'm going
one of that adventure.
And I'm just like, okay,
surely when I play out
pay off this mortgage,
that's when the game play.
Okay. So I play, I play
animal crossing and I, and I
and I paid Tom Nick back
or whatever the his name is, I pay off my
I pay off my mortgage.
Cause I'm just like, there
must be a reason why every game
every magazine is giving
this five stars pay
off my mortgage and then
the game just continues.
And then it looks like
- No
- Okay. Because you like
games like banjo Kazooie
or like JPGs where
there's like a whole like
collect like a collecting element to it.
Right.
- Linear games, more than
OpenWorld and stuff like that.
- I, I do like linear
games more than open.
I like, I, it's funny because I feel
like I do like the idea
of open-world games.
But if I'm going to sit
down and play something
then I'd much prefer linear games.
Right.
- Because one of my favorite aspects
of animal crossing personally is
like the whole like catching fish
and bugs and collecting all the artworks
and collecting all the furniture.
So like, it's basically the
collecting portion of it.
Whereas a lot of other people
who play the game, you know
enjoy the whole, like,
you know, DIY, you know
creating your own amazing looking town
amazing looking house kind of thing.
To me, that's like second number one
for me is definitely like, I needed to
complete my fish index need
to complete my bug index.
Why, why, why do you want to do that?
Because I got that from
playing all the JPGs.
Right. And like, and obviously
six is up there because like
there was that for six, for me as well.
But like, I think the
reason why I picked six
and I think why final
fantasy six is my favorite
not only final fantasy game
but my favorite JPG Evo is because like
it was the first game where I was like
this is a work of art, right?
Like this is not just a game.
It's like, the gameplay is like, cool.
You know, I've played all
the previous final fantasies
like four and one and like that.
Right. This game plays basically the same
but six was the first time
where I was like, I didn't know
story could be this good.
I didn't know, game
music could be this good.
I didn't know.
You could have this much
emotion in a game where
and I got to like the fake,
like the fact that, you know
people still talk to this day
about like the final fight scene, right?
Yeah. Like final fantasy six.
I feel like it's overshadowed
by final fantasy seven
but everyone I know who's
played final fantasy six
holds it higher than final fantasy.
So I've always said
the true final fantasy.
That's like six is the true
final fantasy fans pick.
Yeah. Right.
Because it's like, you're not persuaded
by like the graphics quote unquote
because this was the
last 2d final fantasies.
Aren't seven is roadblocks
or seven is roadblocks
but people still put it on this
like pedestal of graphics.
Right. It's like, what are you seeing?
And like, you know, don't get me wrong.
It's also a good game.
Yeah. I also like seven,
but six was, I don't know.
There's something about
it where it was like
this game could look like absolute.
Right. And the story and
the music and everything
just the emotion of getting
into this world is so
well done where it's like
I don't care how this game looks.
Yeah. And was it like to this day
like the battle thing,
the decisive battle thing
for final fantasy six gives me a Harlem.
Every time I listen to it, it's
like the Sona five and
final fantasy, six easily
have the best battle
theme music, any game.
- I mean, I can't comment already.
I haven't played any final
fantasy, so I felt bad.
I can't judge yours.
- There's a lot of, there's a lot
of final fences that could have put
on hating turn-based battle was yeah
- I am.
I am regretting not putting
I wish I put ruined scape on my list now.
Oh yeah.
I'm surprised you just gave
wasn't on your, I forgot.
Played rune scape.
That was like the first game
I ever liked had a membership
for actually maybe club penguin.
I don't know.
Yeah. Called penguin.
I was the first one for me.
- Penguin on my list.
- Going on those tubes
down the, the snow slope.
- Tipping, the ice becoming the
- Asian bro.
It's typically I, Oh God.
Yeah. Greenscape light.
Definitely. Like when you
say emotion in the world, man
I was so into those quests and.
Oh yeah.
Going to like monkey Island and stuff.
Oh my God.
So good.
- Yeah. I want to be one to
remake my three by three off
to talking to you guys about
it, but honestly make it three
by three of like each console.
Do you want to talk about tomorrow too?
So Rory.
Okay. Terraria for me was like
so when it came out, I had
already like known Minecraft
- Because Minecraft obviously came
up before Terraria Minecraft, not on here.
And Terraria is
I thought you liked
Minecraft more than Troy.
- I think Minecraft for me
is kind of like, I like it
and it's a game that I
can always come back to
but I don't think I was like
as heavily into it as I was
with Terraria.
I think Tara came out when I
was in maybe like middle school
or high school or something.
And the only, ever time
where I would spend
like I would not sleep
and being like a Skype call with
- My friends in high school
was playing Terraria.
- Like there was so many nights
where after school, you know
we'd be on the bus home.
We'd be like, all right
we're playing Terraria after dinner.
Yeah. Like seven, 8:00 PM.
Yeah. Cool.
We all get on a Skype call and we played
for until like 6:00 AM, like, all right.
So you in school in two hours
like I had so many nights
like that playing Terraria.
Right. I don't know why I
could have easily done that
with Minecraft, to be honest.
But I think it's because I don't know.
There's something about
like side scrolling games
that just, just, just tickle my fancy.
- It looks fun.
Every time I see Terraria, I'm like, yeah
that looks like fun.
I just, yeah.
I mean, it's kind of like
- Why is there a point to Minecraft?
It's kind of like the point of mine.
I mean, there is actually like a story
- Where it's like, you
have to go through and like
this is like a bunch
of story Dungeons kind of thing
that you have to discover.
There is an end game.
- That's just a bunch of content for free.
Right. But everyone's always
like the Chad Terraria DLC
for free, something like that.
Exactly. And I think I have Terraria.
I think I paid for it.
I just never played it.
I don't know.
- It's really, really fun.
And it's, it's, it's like
Minecraft for me as well
where it's like, if I
just need like a game to
just kind of mindlessly play
and just relaxed too, then I'll
either put in Minecraft or terrarium.
Yeah. Yeah.
Other than that, other
than that, it is the most
- Vanilla three by three I've ever made.
I mean, I, I mean, I
totally understand why
- Three by three, this is very
much a Joey three by three
- Nine games that I can
always come back to.
And it's probably the most amount
of time I've ever spent on any.
Yeah.
- I wrote down a bunch
of other games that I
wish I could have put
on borderlands too.
I thought it was really good legal legends
Gary's mode on here.
Maybe portal to Mario party to
- Yeah. I, I I'm, I'm surprised
nobody put Mary party here
because I wanted to talk about Mary story.
Mission challenge, hands down the best
the amounts of blisters I've
gotten from Mary parcel.
God, whoever designs
the like whoever designed
the end 64 controller
like he just hated humanity.
He woke up and he chose violence.
He would like put it
into games where I'm like
- I'm sure there's better solutions rowing
down the rubbing down a like a raft thing.
Yeah.
- So the man, just the
managers saw an ergonomics book
and just set it on fire.
Like, well, because yeah, like
I said, with the rowing one
- The mechanic was to like, go this way.
If you wanted the boat to go
this way or go the other way
if you wanted to go that way
I'm pretty sure if I might
be wrong, I think so.
I'm like, you could have
just done literally else.
Like why did you know?
There's like Ellen Audra?
- I think my favorite Mario party
to mini game was I think
it was on Mario party too.
It was the one where you
have to, like, there was like
it was like swamps, domino.
I love that.
no, you have to like mash
a, Oh, knock down as many.
Like, I love the one, the
skateboarding one as well.
- The blow up the balloon,
like as full as you think it
can go.
That was a good one.
That was a good, the fact
that like the go-karting one
go cardio on socks.
What I love about too is just that
- around.
It does not hold your hand.
It's like, if you up, you
up. Yeah, sure.
Good Pokemon Colosseum.
Oh, for me.
- The one with the story
we could catch other.
People's poke them on the dock.
I
- Go super into Pokemon snap.
Well, snap was a new one coming out.
- Yeah. We're recording
on the 30th of March.
- Oh wow.
Wait, wait two sports.
God professor Layton.
I actually really liked those games.
I played the first one.
It was pretty good.
Yeah.
- You mentioned for the
worst game I ever bought
in my life.
I completely regret it.
We music probably you've seen this game.
No garbage.
Can you had to buy it
with a controller as well.
So it was like 90 bucks
when you were a kid.
So I asked my parents for it
cause I was like, wow, look
I should get on me a Moto on stage, whack.
Like you, you get this game.
And literally the play, the instruments.
You're just like waggle the controller.
And it sounds like.
And like that's the whole day.
That's the whole, I'm
going to show you it later.
You're gonna be like,
you have to like conduct.
You can conduct a doesn't
work very well at all.
I mean, this one where you
like can play a trumpet
and all you do is press the
button and hold the Weaver
like this.
And then this one where you play guitar
and just gives
- Garbage.
Oh, you want to go for me?
Horizon zero Dawn.
I mean, I, I feel that
self-explanatory anything
with a good story and a good
character is fire emblem.
Three houses put fire emblem awakening.
Oh, okay.
The gameplay more than
the story environment.
Yeah. I mean, the reason
I put three houses on is
because I'm air about the gameplay.
Cause it's turn base, but
it was just fire emblem
with persona.
And I'm just like, yeah,
literally this is everything
I need.
Like this gives me reason
to get you through, get play
through the game.
Metroid, Metroid prime, incredible.
And that was one of the few
games where I'm totally invested
in the world.
And it wasn't again, what
I, when I went again, went
against what I said
before, because you have to
kind of figure it out yourself.
Yeah. But the game play
with that was so good.
That's I, I, I wanted to yeah.
Walking dead season one.
I mean that's the telltale game.
Wow. That was, I mean, it was good.
And then it became bro.
I mean, it wasn't really a game.
It was just a good story.
Yeah. For me, I Okami
is up there really good.
Obviously I said rhythm heaven
- Linked to the past we sports.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Smash bros melee obviously.
- And then like recently
like I recently just played
like the two Bayonetta games.
Yeah. Those were really good too.
Honestly, this, this too many way.
Like why, why, why do we have
to just confine it to nine?
- Let's talk about like a five by five.
The Masonic riders.
What I've realized after
doing this episode is
that there are so many games that I love
that I just did not remember because I, I
I go back to my comfort
pigs, but man, there's a
there's a lot of games there.
- The one game that we're all gonna, like
if we have to pick one game off the today
that we have that we're going to go back
and play red load too.
- This is tricky for me.
Honestly, you didn't
mention the soundtrack
of SSX tricky just because
the amount of time that game.
So good to play man.
Cause I realized the reason
I freaked out was because
for the longest time,
I couldn't remember why
I wanted to learn snowboarding so bad.
I had just thoughts that
snow snowboarding seems cool.
I didn't listen to the theme.
As you were learning to snowball.
I did not.
And let me stop at you.
I like you had just reminded me
as to say it's tricky
is the sole reason why
I wanted to snowboard so bad.
And that's why I'm just
like Tony Hawk's pro
skater two was the reason
why I wanted to learn how to skate.
I just blanked out that memory of my life.
good, good game.
- Ah, it wasn't on any of all this
but I really want to play theme park.
So many games.
The stream boys for halo Wars with me.
- I mean, like I, I think, I
think we've gotten a good taste
of what our tastes in video games are.
I wonder
- More like viewers, are you
more of a gone Connor or Joey?
I wonder, let us know down in the corner
who is the best taste and why is it me?
It's Sonic writers.
Writers. Battalion was two.
Why is it the best?
I'll fight anyone.
Yeah.
- I love the, how this
has probably been the most
civil episode regarding our tastes.
It's
- Like animating your dog, gaming.
- Sonic riders.
I totally respect more for that.
I thought I was going
to get great for that.
What the?
I think it was because me
and Joey aren't true gamers.
Just like casual, casual,
but Hey, let's give a special
thank you to our patrons.
Look at them.
They're all beautiful people.
Wonderful. And payments
- Game is pro game is so many
of them have to throw in one
naked Jakey reference that.
- No, it just just had to
do it of course, but Hey
if you'd like to support the show
and then make sure to
go over to our patriarch
- Toronto slash trash taste,
also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your memes on the subreddit.
And if you hate our faces,
listen to us on Spotify.
- Yeah. There's nothing else to say.
Go game.
- Goodbye gamers.
I hope you're listening to this
while playing every game we mentioned
for optimum gaming experience.
Honestly, you've just
swept the cartridge when
we mentioned the game.
Yep. All right.
Well I guess the, yeah, that's it.
There's nothing else to say.